what is up guys fire here from awesome
dudes calm Oh heaven said that in a
while anyways before we start creating
anything I am going to preview the game
that you are going to create so I'm
gonna hit the play button and you will
see now that we have our warriors that
they will fight each other don't mind
the buttocks that you can see from the
character so you see the enemy is
chasing us in trying to attack us
actually he hit me pay attention to you
the health bars at the top left and top
right corner and by the way I can hold
the shield like this when I hold the
shield he is not able to attack and now
when I lowered the shield he will be
able to attack you can hear the public
behind in the background let me just up
the volume of it so you can hear them
cheering they like when blood is spit
anyways I'm going to attack the enemy
and as you can see I am dealing more
damage because hey I don't want to lose
in the game that I'm creating I don't
want to embarrass myself
and when his help gets to zero basically
I have to hit him two more times so one
more time back you see now he is dead
and voila I have won and the enemy's
health is zero as you can see at the top
right corner basically this is the game
that you are going to create we have
maybe battle system something we did not
do before we have enemy AI that enemy
can detect where the player is and it
will chase that player also when the
player goes away a little from the enemy
the enemy starts chasing the player
again so let's start creating this I
mean a new project let me close this one
because I don't want it to be open let
me close it like this so right click
here and finally it's closed anyways
this is our project here we have our
sample thing this is a new 3d project by
the way so you're simply gonna go and
create a new 3d project name it however
you want to name it I named this one
warrior fight game this sample scene I
am going to change the gameplay just so
I like to name things correctly and we
are going to import the assets by the
way the assets and
complete project are available for you
to download link is in the description
below so select all of these assets
mogul sounds textures and UI and simply
drag and drop them right here inside of
unity of course it will take a moment or
two for unity to load all of this you
know the procedure it takes some time to
import the 3d assets and yeah while we
wait I can sync to you or we can stop
the video let's actually try the singing
I'm just kidding I'm gonna stop the
video come back when everything is
finished
finally unity took mercy upon us and it
has imported all the assets and we can
start building our game the first thing
that I want to do is create the terrain
or the ground where we are going to
stand and for that I'm simply going to
right click here in the hierarchy panel
and go under 3d object and create a
simple cube voila this is our terrain
now of course not this cube we aren't
gonna stand on a cube actually we are
but I'm going to resize it and I'm going
to call it ground for the scale X I'm
going to c104 scale Y point 1 because I
want to make it you know 10 like this I
don't want to make it you know large I
don't know what's opposite of 10 don't
judge me
anyways I'm going to say here is Z 100
as well
voila this is what we have this going to
be our terrain now of course it is not
pretty at all I don't want this
whiteness tearing my eyes apart so if
you pay attention here inside of the
folders or the assets that we have
imported we have textures instead of
textures we only have this grass texture
if I open it this is the grass texture
basically this somebody took a shot in
his backyard anyways what we're gonna do
here is we are inside of the textures
I'm going to right click and create a
new material so here it is right click
and create so again it's right-click and
go under create and material this is
what we want and I'm going to call this
one ground material and we are going to
apply it on the ground so now I can drag
and drop this on the
and this is how you make game objects
look cool basically because pay
attention to our ground it's white if I
put this material on it it's still white
though but what I can do for example is
I can change the color to now red or
dark or silver or whatever but I can
also drag and drop this grass inside of
this albedo or I'll buy no I don't have
my highlight till here it is so if I
take here as you can see I have the
grass and if I drag and drop it right
here it will display that grass voila
on our ground voila this is how you make
things look good in unity and in 3d but
there is more to these materials and
shaders now this is the first time I
mentioned shaders so what our shaders
basically a shader determines how that
material or the texture that is applied
to that material looks like so if I take
here pay attention I have the standard
shader this is on the drop-down list
right here so here it is I'm
highlighting that with my highlight tool
so when you click on that it's a
drop-down list and you can play with all
the different shaders you have built and
of course there are others that you can
import from the asset store but these
are built in what I like to use is this
one unlit texture and you see it's
already a little bit different it's a
little bit darker so the grass looks a
little bit darker in comparison to what
it looked like a moment ago and I
encourage you to experiment with these
shaders so that you can see their
effects not every shader will make your
material look good maybe some will look
bad others will look better but you can
find that out if you experiment so for
example if i go here i don't know nature
and say speed tree maybe this will not
make it look good well basically it's a
little lighter and some shaders also
have other fields here where you can add
a texture you can have a normal texture
now I'm not going to go into that that's
a different topic and I don't know too
much about it the basic
when you combine these textures like a
normal map another texture some other
textures that come along with it you
make your material look or the game
object that has that material look good
anyways what you need to do is simply
experiment with these just experiment
try them out and see different effects
that you will get and that's how you
learned the best now moving forward we
have our ground and again the scale X is
100 and Z is 100 y is point 1 why well
because pay attention if I said the Y
for example at 100 I don't want this
what the hell is this you see we don't
want this we only want our ground so we
want to make it look like a ground
that's why I put the scale so that it's
not too large on the y axis so moving
forward if I go back in assets and
models we have the arena here in side of
the models folder so in the models
folder we have the arena if I click here
this is our arena if I drag and drop it
here it is this is the arena now of
course it's too small so we need to
resize it make sure it is positioned at
0 0 0 for x y and z and I'm going to
call it battle arena so this is the name
of the game object and the scale for XY
and Z is going to be 25 so 25 25 25 and
voila this is our arena
it already has materials applied on it
if you click on the drop-down list
you'll see all of these different game
objects that are put together to make
this arena if I you know deactivate some
of them so if I let's try the activities
you see the effect if I deactivate them
well they are gone so that is another
thing that you can experiment but
basically these are just 3d models put
to get put together to create this
battle arena you can see here we have
some people's spectating or whatever
yeah this we're look at that weirdo yeah
these two and they're probably up to
something yeah anyways I don't know what
I'm saying but this is our battle arena
now moving forward we are going to
import our character and here he is our
warrior now one thing to note is this is
headless warriors if I drag and drop him
here and if I go to him
voila this is a headless warrior like a
headless swordsman but of course we are
going to make him with head so I don't
know how you say head what's opposite of
headless had hand honest I don't know
anyways this is our game object so what
I'm gonna do is first of all I'm going
to take and rename it so from body
underscore zero I'm going to rename it
to warrior next we need to apply this
head on him so if you pay attention to
the head now it's too big we are not
gonna void we're not gonna do this to
him any did you do the head look at that
we're not gonna do this to him we are
going to resize the head a little so I'm
going to resize it let's say here head
is been 1 1 1 actually no so the head is
gonna be 1.5 1.5 and 1.5 yeah exactly so
1.5 heard the head this is totally fine
and we need to select the warrior click
on this drop-down list to go through all
of the elements that make him or his
body parts so click on the warrior then
this be IP 0 0 1 click on that drop down
list and again you have be IP 0 0 1
pelvis click on that one and let me just
resize this here then we are gonna go
under spine then spine 1 then spine -
man this model is killing me then we
have the neck and right here we have the
head so what you can also do is in the
search bar if I take the highlight tool
here you have the search bar in the
hierarchy panel you can also select the
search bar and you can type here for
example head and it will find it for you
it's this one right here be IP 0 0 1
head so this is the part of the body
that we need so now we're gonna drag and
drop the head right here normally we
don't have to do this because other
models come with the head but this model
is like this so what I'm gonna do is I
am going to resize it or actually
reposition it
I'm going to say 0.016
this is going to be for the X for the Y
it's going to be zero point zero one two
and for the Z it's gonna be negative
zero point let's say here I don't it's
gonna leave it just at zero just as you
leave the Z at zero and I think his head
is all it's also still too big so yeah
this is okay and let's take here and
resize the handle a bit so the scale is
gonna be point four seven or XY and Z I
think now it's okay so when you select
the head set the scale to point four
seven that is zero point four seven for
x y&z the position X X is going to be
negative zero point zero two seven four
and Y is going to be zero point zero one
two and yeah this is where our head is
going to be exactly and it looks good it
looks good actually look like it's
already built on him anyways as I said
we are not gonna do this that often
because most models come with the head
but this one is like this and what we
can do or yeah anyways select the
warrior now and what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to click on this add component
here and we are going to filter for
character controller this is a built-in
controller that comes with unity so if I
select it here again it's under add
component and filter here character
controller as I said this is a built-in
controller and I don't know if you can
see the green things around him so yeah
I've turned off the ground and the
ballerina so we can see this capsule
thing around him
basically this character controller
comes with a Collider and also comes
with aa rigid body in it so we don't
have to apply these things this green
thing that you can see is a Collider
that's around our player so what we can
do is we can reposition it so I'm going
to put it on my point nine six and for
the X I'm going to leave it Z I'm going
to
even radius however is gonna be point 25
and voila you see the radius it will
resize that collider now it can be a
little lower I don't know for example
0.21 yeah and you can see now it is
around our player well around the middle
of him and this is as I said the
character controller that we are going
to use in order to make him move and by
the way let me just put him like this so
if I put him like this and if I hit the
play button actually where's my camera
he is standing still now even though we
have a rigidbody we have a velocity in
our character controller we still need
to apply gravity on him so we need to
apply gravity and in order to apply
gravity basically we do that VI script
so it's time to get our hands dirty
let's go back in the assets and right
click here and create a new folder which
I'm going to call scripts inside of the
scripts folder we are going to
right-click and create our player move
script and by the way before we continue
what I'm gonna do is go back here in
assets and right-click and create a
folder this one is going to be our
prefabs and click here in the prefabs
and drag and drop the warrior so BAM
this is our warrior prefab now so we
don't have to worry about deleting this
game object from the scene and doing all
of this from beginning so if we go back
in the scripts we have the player move
script drag and drop it on the warrior
and now hit apply here so that that
change applies to the prefab now one
thing I want to get out right now
I like when I go and spontaneously have
things that I need to explain why we
need to hit apply to make that change
apply to the prefab and you if you're
watching my tutorials you probably heard
me saying that like a thousand times
well this prefab right here is basically
now the original game object of this
warrior that we have in the hierarchy so
let me just take it
so this warrior here in the prefabs
folder is the original one
one right here is a copy of it any
change we apply to this copy for example
if I go here and if I attach an audio
source component pay attention here I
have attached an audio source component
on the copy in the hierarchy the
original one the warrior here in the
prefabs folder he does not have that
audio source applied on him because we
attach that one on the copy if you want
to have the original have this audio
source because you attached it you will
need to click on this apply and this
apply applies that to the original
prefab which is right here here it is
the original prefab in the prefabs
folder so if I select that warrior
prefab in the prefabs folder it has the
audio source component attached on him
now but pay attention now if I go here
to warrior and remove and this is the
warrior in the hierarchy the copy if I
now remove the audio source component
the original still has the source
component the audio because we did not
hit apply but pay attention to the
difference now if however I select the
warrior inside of the prefabs folder the
original one and if I go here for
example and filter for a rigidbody
component and if I apply that rigidbody
component on the original what do you
think for the copy it will have the
rigidbody applied because we applied it
under original and the copy will simply
follow because it's a copy of the
original but if we apply to the copy
then we need to click apply to make that
change apply to that prefab the original
one as well so if I remove now from the
warrior prefab the original one we also
don't have it on the copy prefab so I
hope this clears things out if not ask
what is not clear in the comments below
so let me go here actually this is from
the previous one the one that I have
previewed it so moving forward this is
the new one that we are going to code
from scratch let me just click here and
hold enter to give a little bit space so
what do we need for our player move
first of all we need our private
character controller and I'm going to
call it char controller like this not
character but char like this short for
character we will also need an animator
but we will do that later on we also
need here public float movement speed
which is by default three and pay
attention I said it's to be public which
means it is editable in the inspector
panel and what do I mean by this one I
say it is editable in the inspector
panel that means the public variable is
visible here in the inspector pay
attention here now you see we have it
right here let me click on the highlight
tool and here it is so we have it it's
right here which means we can manipulate
this value if I set here value five now
we have the value five and not three so
if I put it back at three it is three
basically the value that we put here in
the inspector panel will override the
value that is here so we have the
movement speed we also have a public
float gravity this is what I was talking
about which is 9.8 this is the gravity
in real life as well we also have a
public float rotation so rotation speed
which is gonna be equal to 0.15 F we
also have our public float rotate the
grease per second which is going to be
equal to 180 degrees per second so these
are the variables that we need to get
started and the first thing that I'm
gonna do is inside of the awake function
of course we have the start but I'm
going to change it to awake if you are
also following my tutorials you know
that I like to initialize things in the
awake function because that order of
execution goes like this when we run our
game this is the first function that is
called the second function that is
called is on enable this one right here
and
is the second function and the third
function is start so start is the third
function but by default when we create a
project we have start an update of
course we can use start for
initialization and in some cases it is
better to use start over awake for
example and I know somebody will ask
when is that case well if you are
initializing something in the awake
function and you need to get a reference
for that then initialize it in the awake
but get the reference in the start
function this goes for example if you
select a player in the main menu will
you initialize the player in the
gameplay scene in awake but you need to
follow it with the camera then in the
camera use the code that will find the
player in the start function we will
have examples for this in some other
tutorials so don't worry about that
anyways I'm going to see here chart
controller is equal to get component
character controller and while we are
basically done with our character
controller what is the next thing to do
is go here and create void move and this
is a function that we are going to use
to move which we are gonna call in the
update and here we're gonna have move so
what are we going to do here first of
all we are going to test if input get
access and here we are going to say
vertical like this he is greater than
zero which means if we have either press
the up arrow key or the W key on our
keyboard because if I take here quickly
the highlight tool and this is the
coordinate system so here we have Y here
we have X and here we have Z because
this is a 3d game and basically up on
the Y is plus down is minus on the x
axis to the right is plus which means
the positive side in on the left is
negative and for the Z forward is the
positive and backwards is the negative
and basically here
yes we are testing if we are touching
the vertical axis which is the y axis
that's the vertical axis but we are
going to use this to move our character
forward and right here below we are
going to say else if input I've get axes
and here we're going to say vertical if
that is less than zero then that means
we are going downwards and to paint a
clearer picture I'm going to use here
print and I'm going to see the value is
and I'm going to see here plus and we're
going to use this input and vertical so
that you can see the output actually of
this what this value will be so if I go
back here in unity and let me go into
the console and clear it so if I hit the
play button pay attention now as long as
I'm not pressing anything it will be
zero but when I start pressing so I
started pressing actually did not so now
I'm gonna start pressing and I'm
pressing the up arrow key and this is
what we have let me just go here because
it happened so fast it's in the update
function it updates every frame in a
second so pay attention here this is
where I started to press and notice the
value is 0.04 then 0.096 then 0.14 then
2 and and 3 1 up to 1 so it goes from 0
up to 1 in these increments that we just
saw so 0.1 and 0.15 then 0.2 so on and
so forth you get my point and for the
negative if you press down that is the S
key or the down arrow key you will get
from 0 to negative 1 and then you saw
the increment it goes slowly from 0 up
to 1 if you want to go directly from 0
to 1 then you will use get axis or raw
get access raw has the same exact effect
it will detect when you click or
actually when you press the up arrow key
or the W key or when you press the S key
or the Dan down arrow key but when you
press the up key and W it will return
from 0 to 1 but will go directly from 0
to 1
it will not go in these increments that
we just saw you can print this and see
for yourself
now one other thing that I don't like
about this code is this right here not
the word vertical but instead me hard
coding values this is something I don't
like to do so if we go here in unity and
go back in the project tab inside of the
scripts folder I'm going to right-click
and create a new script that I'm going
to call tags so tags and here I'm going
to double click it we're not going to
attach it on any game object and I am
going to remove this public class
declaration so what are we going to do
why why this why did this go right here
so what are we going to do within our
class well first of all I'm going to
create here a public class called axis
and here we're going to have a public
constant string and I'm going to call
this one vertical so vertical axis which
is gonna be equal to vertical like this
and we're also going to have a public
constant string and this one is going to
be horizontal so horizontal axis which
is gonna be equal to horizontal as you
can assume because we're gonna have
vertical and horizontal now don't mind
these red errors that I have this
because my computer was open for such
many time or for so long so I have to
close visual studio and reopen it again
to make this actually work so now when
its open BAM here it is
so now everything is working like a
charm as I said I don't like hard coding
values like here because if we use this
on two places or even more it can happen
that I misspelled something because if I
type vertical with lowercase V it's not
gonna work even though the word is the
same so capitalization needs to be the
same and when we use it like this when
you
when we declare it in a single place we
can simply do this we instead of typing
it like this we simply say here AK sees
that vertical axis and bam this is it
and here we do the same thing axes the
vertical axis and back it's the same
exact thing except here we have it in
one place and notice here this constant
constant will not change same like in
math now you don't have to be Imagineers
to know that but basically if I do
something like this if I say X is that
vertical axis is equal to me changing it
it is not going to work because it's a
constant anyways moving forward now we
are detecting if we touch or if we press
the up arrow key or the W key and here
if we press the down arrow key and the s
key so if we press the up arrow key we
want to move forward and in order to do
that we're gonna see here vector three
move direction is gonna be equal to you
transform forward what the hell is this
transform forward well if I hover over
it says the blue axis of the transform
in the world space in order to paint a
clearer picture if I take my warrior
here inside of the scene and i zoom him
on him do you see this blue axis this
blue arrow that I'm taking and dragging
him this is that axis indicating the
forward so no matter where he is because
we can rotate him if I do something like
this and I rotate and you see now for it
is this way not the way where it was so
basically it was this way forward but
when we rotate him you saw what I mean
and this right here the transform
forward is telling us the move direction
is to move forward so now we're simply
going to say move direction that Y minus
equals gravity multiplied with
time.deltatime in order to apply gravity
this is what I was talking about in the
beginning so when we attach actually the
character controller I said that we need
to manually apply gravity to our
character and this is how we do it this
is how we apply gravity by subtracting
from Y gravity multiplied with time
at the time why time that Delta time
well because we are calling the move
function in the update and if you want
to smooth out things because update is
called every frame or actually once per
frame if we have 60 frames in a second
that's 60 times in a single second this
function will be called which means this
one will be called as well because we
are calling it in the update now if we
subtract from Y gravity only which is
9.8 that's a very very it's gonna happen
very fast it's a huge number and we are
subtracting that every frame 60 times in
a second that's why we need to multiply
it what time that Delta time and times
Delta time is the difference between
each frame so how many time you took to
go from last frame to the next one that
is the Delta time and it's a very low
value and this y on that that is the
reason why we use it to smooth things
out so moving forward we have here
applying our gravity the next thing to
do simply call our character controller
and move in order to move our game
object so we pass here the move
direction this is where we want to move
multiplied with the movement speed
multiplied with the time that Delta time
to smooth things out again smoothing
things out with time that Delta times
same reason as what I explained right
here and this is we're moving in this
direction but we are multiplying that
with the speed movement in order to
speed up the movement now what I'm gonna
do is here for our negative or actually
when it's lower than zero that means we
need to go backwards so I'm simply going
to copy these lines of code and pays
them right here and since we don't have
transform backwards we have forward but
we don't have backwards I'm simply going
to use the negative so I'm gonna say
minus transform forward which is simply
the negative of forward watch is what is
negative for up forward it's backwards
think of it as opposites so this is
going to have the same effect except
backwards and here we are using move
direction which is now backwards
multiplying that with
moving speed multiply that with the time
delta time and we can test it out so if
I go here and then one thing another tip
from me take notes when I say these tips
if you want for example if this is where
you want your camera to look for example
in your scene or when you run the game
instead of using the camera and
positioning it I know I don't know it's
ten twenty thirty position for example
and this is where that position is or
dragging it and dropping it simply what
you're gonna do is position here the
view how you want it or where you want
the camera to look in the scene select
the main camera in the hierarchy and on
Mac hold shift in command on Windows
it's control command and press F so when
you press F so now pay attention where
the camera is exactly same place where
we are looking in our scene now that we
have that done I can hit the play button
and I can test this out so we have the
player in voila I'm pressing the W key
now pressing the arrow key up arrow key
and W he's moving forward I'm pressing
the back arrow key and I'm pressing the
S key he is moving backwards so a lot
this works the next thing on our agenda
is to rotate our game object or the
player so let me just go here and this
one is for the move and here void rotate
and this one is for the rotate which we
are gonna call right here in the move so
we're gonna say a rotate like this
because move is called in the update and
we can safely call rotate below it or
you can simply take the rotate outside
and you can call it here it does not
matter it's the exact same effect so in
the rotate we are going to say here
vector 3 which is the rotation
underscore direction by default I'm
gonna say it's equal to vector 3 0 this
is the default one because vector 3 0 is
a shorthand for writing vector 3 0 0 0
for x y&z because we're gonna detect
input again we're gonna say if you put
that get axis and we're gonna see here
axis horizontal axis if that
value is greater or actually if it's a
lower than zero and here we're gonna say
else if input not get access and again
here access that horizontal now here
we're gonna test if is greater than zero
and then we're gonna do the following so
if it's lower than zero that means we
are pressing the a key again this is the
coordinate system this is the horizontal
axis meaning the x axis going to the
right side is the positive going to the
left side is the negative so if we press
the a key or the left arrow key we're
going to the left side which is negative
which means this right here will be
lower than zero if that is the case
we're simply gonna see here a rotation
direction he is gonna be equal to you
transform that transform point or
actually transform direction and here
we're gonna say vector three dot left
now I'm simply gonna copy this and paste
it here and you can assume that here
it's gonna be vector three dot right and
by the way this one is going to be
separate so we're not going to do if
else or else if and why what did he give
me this axis here anyway here I'm going
to say if input get access we are not
gonna use if-else simply we're gonna do
if and if because we can press these
buttons simultaneously so if we press
the a key or the D key that would cancel
each other out anyways moving forward
what is this transform direction well if
I hover over it's gonna say transforms
the direction from local space to world
space what is that what is local space
what is world space let's go back in
unity to explain the local space if I
take the warrior and of course I'm gonna
go in the scene first and zoom in on the
warrior this is my warrior game object
if I right-click on him and create an
empty game object that I'm going to tag
here with this orange or yellow tag you
see this game object right now inside of
our so he's basically inside of our game
object our hero if I move him here and
now he is in front of him if I take the
X
that zero take the white said it at zero
take the zi7 at zero now he is back at
the centre and his centre is around his
warrior player that his his local axis
that is the local axis his own origin so
his own origin of that game object and
with origin I mean where that game
object goes when we set zero zero zero
for x y and z or when we reset the
position on the transform where does he
go that is his origin or Aki's local
axes local position that is if I go here
you see transform direction from local
space to world space but what is the
world space well world spaces all of
this here you see everything that we see
here so where our cube is are actually
our ground where our battle arena is
where our player is that is unique YZ
world space and this is where we are
moving when we move this character we
are moving him in the unities world
space that's where everything happens so
we are transforming the direction here
which is vector three left and if you go
here a shorthand for writing negative 1
for x 0 0 for y and z and the right is
positive 1 for X 0 for X for y and z
basically we are transforming this into
the world space and this will transform
it into the left side of our game object
inside of world space and it will do the
same thing here for the right direction
so now that we have the input for the
left and the right direction we have
here the rotation direction right here
we are gonna say if input that or
actually now we need to rotate our game
object so we are gonna say if a rotation
direction is not equal to vector 3.0 so
if it's not equal to 0 that means that
we have here input and that's the reason
why I'm setting it here to be equal to 0
because we are resetting it every time
if we don't reset it resected reset it
here then the value that we get here
will stay the same and here it was Davis
every single time so we need to
basically reset it here to zero so
vector 3 0 but if it's not equal to
vector 3 0 that means we got input here
so what we're gonna do is simply we're
gonna say transform a rotation is equal
to u quaternion that rotates towards and
this will rotate from rotation that is
from the transform rotation to rotation
it's gonna be quaternion look rotation
it's gonna be a rotation direction in
the given speed and are actually degrees
and the degrees is gonna going to be a
rotate degrees per second multiplied
with time that delta time what the hell
is going on here teacher what are you
doing you are driving me crazy and okay
let me just calm down calm down I'm
gonna not drive drive you crazy anymore
anyways we see here transform rotation
is gonna be equal to this rotates
towards you see here rotates a rotation
from towards to this is from so it will
rotate from this rotation to this
rotation in basically these or this
degrees but this is clear it will rotate
from the current rotation it has towards
this rotation right here now look
rotation basically creates a rotation
with a specified forward and upward
direction basically this will do the
following since we are rotating around
the y axis this is the y axis and it
will create a rotation around the y axis
and the forward will be placed on the y
axis basically if that Y rotates over
here so now Y is here then the forward
will be here you get my point
now the reason for that is because let
me take our warrior you see here pay
attention pay attention to the blue axis
so this one right here if I rotate here
you see you see how the blue axis
rotates along with him basically this is
what we are doing with luke rotation it
will look at the rotation from the y
axis it will basically rotate it from
the y axis which
we want we want to rotate on the y axis
and this is the degrees by which we are
rotating the game object so rotation
degrees per second that we added here
180 multiply that with a delta time to
smooth it out if we don't smooth it out
every frame we will rotate exactly 180
degrees and that will be fast really
fast so if you want to test it out you
can do it by simply doing this right
here basically let me just do it just to
test out and show you the effects of the
smooth time so if I go here and if I run
the game so pay attention now if I
rotate you see this is what happens when
you rotate like this you see this is
what happens because we are rotating so
fast this is 180 degrees per second if
we don't multiply it with the Delta time
to smooth it out then you saw the effect
exact same thing will happen for this
here if you don't multiply without the
time exact same thing will happen here
if you don't multiply that with time
that delta time but if I hit the play
button now that we are multiplying that
with delta time pay attention now I'm
gonna press rec right actually so right
you see how he's rotating now smoothly
and left and he is rotating also
smoothly so now we can move and rotate
so now our game object can move and
rotate at the same time you see moving
and rotating and voila so I'm pressing
left and I'm pressing right and he is
rotating towards the direction where I
am pressing voila this is how we move a
character and how we rotate a character
so the next thing to do is to make the
camera follow the player of course we
also need to animate him but using the
camera to follow him will be much easier
because there is less code involved so
I'm gonna right click here and go on
create and C sharp script and I'm going
to call this one camera follow and I'm
going to show you two ways how can we
make the camera follow the player
because this is programming there is
always more than one way to solve a
problem so select the main camera and
drag-and-drop the camera follow script
on the main camera so
I can drop the camera follow script on
the main camera I'm simply going to
double click it and open it here in
Visual Studio and let me just tag the
class and we don't need here that many
lines of code basically we need the
following so we need a private transform
which I'm going to call target and this
is going to be our player we will get to
it in a moment we also need a private
vector3 offset now it's a private
variable because I don't want it to be
accessible in other classes but I also
want it to be visible here in the
inspector panel because I want to edit
it so in order to do that we simply open
square bracket and type serialize
serialize field and voila so open square
bracket close square bracket in between
type serialized field because now if I
go back a community that private
variable will be visible here in the
inspector panel BAM and here it is right
here and you can simply remove what did
I do
so let's go back here and you can simply
let me just hide this so you can simply
remove this line of code to test it out
to see for yourself if you remove it it
will not be visible in the inspector
panel and eat more so moving forward
from the awake function at the start I'm
gonna get the target so I'm gonna say
target is gonna be equal to game object
find the game object with the tag player
tag dot transform because we're getting
the transform property again two things
two issues we have here first of all
this right here is a no no I don't like
it so we need to go back here in our
tags and we're gonna create a public
class called tags and we're simply going
to have a public constant string player
underscore tag which is going to be
equal to player this is the first thing
and the first issue same as with our
axes and I explained that why so if I go
back here remove this and we're gonna
say tags that play your tag it's the
same exact in fact now in order for this
to work you need to make sure that your
player the warrior when you select him
and right here you have the tag property
in the
Specter panel you see where I'm pointing
with the mouse you can click on it so
let me just hide here and you can click
on it and you need to select the player
tag by default I think it's from unity 5
version and upwards you have here a
tagged player if by any chance you don't
have it you're gonna click here on add
tag so click on add tag and now here
where you see tag and list is empty
click on this plus button so this small
pause button right here that I've just
pointed to so when you click on it it
will open this short window you would
thought you will type here your tag
click Save and then that tag will be
available to you so now that you created
a tag you're simply gonna select the
game object go here and tag it so click
on the tag you want to tag it and pay
attention please please this is a tip so
note it down if the name here is player
with P capital case P it needs to be the
same exact name right here if you type
here lowercase P it will not work even
though it's the exact same words of
capitalization also needs to be in order
this is really important so now we have
a reference to our player we have the
offset here inside of our or actually
below the update we're gonna create void
follow player and we are going to call
this function inside of the late update
function so no update but late update
function and what the hell is a late
update well let me first explain it we
have the update function and we have the
fixed update function update function is
called every frame in a second basically
if we have 60 frames in a second then it
will be called 60 times update function
is good for moving a game object using
the transform property or the character
controller as we are already doing and
also for getting input which we are also
doing here so getting input we do that
in the update function fixed update
function is not called every frame but
it's called in a fixed number frame
intervals what does that mean it's
basically called every third or fourth
frame and this right here is dependent
or that is
depending on if we go under edit and go
here under project settings and then
time if you take a look here let me just
clear it with the pencil you see here
this fixed time step it's set to 0.02
it's dependent on that time basically
fixed update function would be called
every 0.02 of a second and it's good for
physics calculations so if you want to
move your game object using the
rigidbody you will do it in the fixed
update but what the heck now is the
weight update well late update is same
as update it will be called every frame
but it will be called after the update
finishes so if we have something like
this for example I don't know
int a B and C and we want to say here C
is equal to a plus B this calculation
will be already done and we can use the
value of C in the late update and it
will be this value here calculating a
plus B and it will give us the value C
and we will be able to use that in the
late update late update is really good
for using code or typing out code that
will be for for example like this you
know that you follow the player because
we are moving the player as you can see
here in the update so in the update we
will calculate his position and he will
arrive at that position so now in the
late update we already know where the
players position is and we can follow
him smoothly now in order to follow the
player smoothly what we simply need to
do is we need to say transform that
position our own position of the camera
is equal to target player so the target
which is the player transform as you can
see right here and we're going to use
the player transform to transform
direction or actually transform the
point and we're going to transform the
point off set so I've said and basically
let me just go here I'm gonna name it
off set position not to be confused with
that rapper offset it's offset position
what is transform point you see here
transforms position from local space to
world space again basically same thing
as what we did with transform direct
it will transform this point from the
local point of the target but pay
attention here pay attention please
we're using here target which is the
players transform as you can see here so
it's the players transform it will
transform that point from the position
of the player so from the position of
the player it will transform that point
and it will transform it from his local
position to the world position and if we
test it out right now
the beauty here is that our main camera
now has these visible in inspector
variables for the offset XY and Z and
what we can do when I hit the play
button you will see now where the camera
is it's basically here but what I can do
is I can move here the y axis I can move
the z axis you see now and I can set it
where exactly I want it to be in order
to follow our player again I can set
here zero for our y axis and basically
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna set this
at 30 so 30 for the camera for the
rotation and zero for the rotation Y but
if I hit the play button now you will
see that it will transform now the
position and what I can do is this
so wallah you see now this is how I can
make the camera follow the player now of
course here for these values I'm gonna
say 2.25 for the Y and for the Z
negative one point nine or actually it
can be a little closer something like
this maybe negative one this depends on
you but now pay attention now that we
saved or actually we did not see these
values because we are in the play mode
what I'm gonna do is click on this gear
icon you see the gear icon on the camera
so click on the gear icon and it will
open this list here and you're gonna
click on copy component so when you copy
the component now if I go back here you
will see that the values are back to
zero because we edit edited those values
inside of the gameplay mode which means
they will not be saved in order to save
it
did that gear icon copy values so now
that we have them copied we're gonna see
here paste component values BAM
and voila so now we have the values here
negative 1 4 C 2.25 4 y and if we test
this out right now if I hit the play
button you'll think that the camera is
gonna follow the player which actually
is the case but if I rotate you see what
is happening this is not the effect that
we want to achieve now we got here the
way we programmed the position of our
camera but we did not take the rotation
into consideration and I like to do
things like this I'd like to show what
is the problem and I'd like to show what
is the solution to the problem because
we are rotating our character we saw
that so we are rotating the character
right here as you can see and let me
just move this backwards so we are
rotating the character but we also need
to rotate the camera so here I need to
see transform that rotation is going to
be equal to target that rotation simple
like that because our transform rotation
is the rotation of the camera so
transform referring to this class or
that game object that's holding this
class so transform and rotation is going
to be equal to the target rotation and
target that rotation is the player's
rotation so the rotation of the player
game object and now if we go back in
unity and if I hit the play button you
will see that when we rotate our player
we will also rotate you see rotating the
player rotating the camera and we can
move the z-axis let's see negative 2
yeah negative 2 you for the z axis
remember that or actually just close the
game select the main camera and set
negative 2 for the z axis so negative 2
if I hit the play button again now we
move forward we rotate the camera
rotates along with the player so this is
how we do it we also set the position
and the rotation if we also want to
follow the rotation of the game object
now is there another way to make the
camera follow the player a more simple
way of course it is because this
programming this is creating an
application
and there are multiple ways always to
solve a certain problem this one is much
simpler and for that I'm simply going to
duplicate the main camera and I'm going
to set this main camera turn off the
first one the main one and this one I'm
going to rename to camera in player so
I'm going to rename it to camera and
player and I'm also going to remove the
camera follow script because we don't
need it so remove component so remove
the component camera follow script and
what I'm gonna do is simply drag and
drop this camera on the warrior game
object and it will make it a child of
the game object so basically now where
ever removed by here the play button
because the parent is moving you see now
the child is moving as well and the best
thing here is you can position the child
wherever you want so we can say the x
position for the camera is going to be 0
the Y position 2.7 and the Z position
can be negative let's say 1.8 so
negative 1.8 will be the V position and
rotation we can leave 30 for X only and
basically this is how it looks like so
you can rotate it like this however you
want it but I'm gonna set it at 30 again
you can experiment with this this is
totally up to you the more you've tried
the more you will learn I encourage you
to try all the time so experiment with
it now that we have this camera as a
child of our player game object I'm
simply going to hit play and when
wherever the player goes in however he
rotates the camera simply follows
without a script because what the parent
game object does the child will follow
and the warrior here is the parent the
topmost parent all game objects when you
click on the drop-down list on the
warrior all these game objects are
children of the warrior game object and
if we click here on the drop-down list
for this be IP 0 0 1 these footsteps our
children are a child game object of this
be IP 0 0 1 son and so forth you get my
point but they all are the child of the
topmost bearing which is the warrior now
we need to hit apply because we attach
this camera in the player but again this
is another solution
depending on your situation so sometimes
you also want to have the camera inside
as a child and it will follow the player
wherever he goes and it's more simple
basically we did two ways one was using
a script and another one is simply
making the camera game object as child
and it will follow the parent wherever
the parent goes the next thing to do is
to create the animations and we're gonna
go here in the models and here we have
the animation so right here I'm going to
right click here where all these
animations are so right click and I'm
gonna create and I'm going to create an
animator controller so click here and
I'm going to call it warrior controller
like this because if I select the game
object which is our warrior you will see
that he already has an animator
component attached on him so here it is
and we simply need to drag and drop this
animator controller the one that we have
just created we need to drag and drop
him right here in this MD field and then
we can add animations to it and we can
control it VI code so if I take here the
word controller drag and drop it here
BAM so this is the controller now we
have it attached on the animator of the
warrior the next thing to do is go
inside of the animator tab itself and
this is where we are going to create the
animations now if you don't have this
tab what you're gonna do is the
following go under window and then you
have here animation and here it is
animator tap so this one right here so
you have the animation you have the
animator we want the anime tour so
animator this one right here now in
order to create these animations
basically we don't need you they are
already created here but we only need to
connect them with the controller so
while you are in the animator tab right
here right click and create state and
empty so right click create state empty
voila this is going to be the idle
animation and in order to rename this
one you see the name is new state if you
want to rename it simply click on it and
now here either in specter panel you
will see here at the top let me just go
here and clear the console actually
clear the pencil so here it is you see
the state this is where you will rename
it and here where it says motion is
where we are going to drag and drop the
motions or our animations so here new
state is going to be idle and simply
what we need to do here is you see we
have the idle 0 and we have the idle
attack so if I select this one this is
that animation if I go here and preview
it so click the animation basically
clicking on the drop-down list for this
idle and here we have idle underscore 0
now if I preview it so if i zoom in on
this preview here at my bottom right
corner and this is the idle animation
I'm not gonna preview the whole
animation because it's long so go back
here in animator click on idle and here
where I said that you need to drag and
drop that animation or motion right next
to it you have a little circle let me
show that circle it's right here you see
when you click on that circle you will
be able to select these animations so
here we have idle 0 and select the isle
0 and voila idle 0 is not here why well
if we go here in the castle it says
animation clip I go 0 cannot be used in
the state I don't legacy animation clips
are not allowed in animator controller
what does that mean basically it means
the way how we import them so we need to
select all of these animation so select
from a tag 0 to I don't attack 0 and
walk select all of these animations and
right here now inside of the inspector
panel on my right side you see here we
have model tab we have the rig animation
material model Sun and so forth click on
the rig tab in the rig table we're gonna
change the animation type from legacy to
generic so again click here generic
click on the drop-down list where it
says legacy which is right here this
right here you see when you click on
that drop-down list you will change it
from legacy to generic and you will hit
apply
back unity will you see like re-import
these assets with this animation type
but it will read in port these as it's
right here only these animations and of
course it takes a little bit of time
where I can use it to sing just kidding
anyway I had fun recording these videos
man anyways animation type will be
generic and you hit apply
and you see unit III imports them and
voila we are good to go
so now select the idle animation click
on the circle and now select the idle
underscore 0 animation it works here is
our idle animation I can even now
preview it if I select the warrior
inside of the hierarchy panel and if I
go into the animation tab so not the
animator tab but animation which is
located here window animation in any
nation this is that animation tab so I
can click here the play button to
preview it and now we are previewing the
we are basically previewing the idle
animation for our player sees like
moving this is all the automation
everything here that you see is
basically the idle animation and why am
i why am I actually running the game
anyways this is the idle animation as
you just saw so let's go back and create
the rest of these animations so we have
here the idle we are also going to have
the walk animation so right click here
create an empty state and I'm going to
call this one walk and I'm going to
click on the little circle and I am
going to select the walk animation we
are also going to have the attack
animation so right click here empty
state and this one is going to be attack
1 and like this we are also going to
have another one for the attack but let
me just click here on the circle and for
the attack 1 I'm going to select attack
underscore 0 and let me just preview it
quickly so attack underscore 0 yeah this
is the one I want and right click again
and create an empty
and this one is going to be attack to
rename it to attack two and for the
state I'm going to select attack
underscore one but let me quickly
preview it here so attack underscore one
if I preview it yeah exactly these two
so underscore or attack underscore zero
and attack underscore one and the last
one is going to be creme empty and this
one is going to be our defend animation
so defend like this and then for our
defend animation I'm going to click on
the circle and here we have
counter-attack damage defense underscore
zero so select the defense underscore
zero again if we preview it it will be
this and you see he is like moving his
arm upwards to defend from the attack so
now we have these animations we need to
now create a script and handle these
animations via script so when we move we
want to simulate or play that move
animation will be attack we want to play
the attack animation you get my point
but how can we do that well in order to
do that we first need to create
something that is called a parameter so
we need to create something that is
called a parameter and here click on the
plus sign so click on the plus sign and
the first parameter that you are gonna
create is gonna be the walk parameter
and if you notice I clicked on the plus
sign and selected the bolt so I'm gonna
do it again so delete it click on the
plus sign and this one is gonna be a
boolean we are going to call him walk so
a boolean walk parameter now the next
parameter we are going to click on the
plus sign here and we are going to
create a trigger and this one is going
to be defend and we are going to click
on the plus button here and create
another trigger this one is going to be
attacked one click on the plus button
trigger and again attack but now too so
attack one and you walk defend attack
one and attack too
these are parameters because we need to
have transitions what are transitions if
I right-click on the idle animation and
I
click here make transition I can now
point on the walk animation and click on
it BAM you see this white line going
from idle to walk that means this is a
transition from idle to walk animation
that means when we call this transition
in our code we will go from idle to walk
animation but this transition in order
for it to happen it needs to have a
condition in this condition he is right
here when you click on this line here
this arrow when you click on it it goes
blue and you have the properties here in
the inspector panel when you scroll a
little bit down you will see here
conditions and it's a list where we can
click on this plus sign to add a
condition well the conditions are gonna
be these right here these parameters so
for example if I click on the plus sign
here and I'm gonna go from idle to walk
when the walk parameter is equal to true
and notice here in the drop down list
I can select true or false because when
we created this parameter it was a
boolean boolean has a value true or
false
so we will go from idle to walk
animation when the walk parameter is or
has a value true and we will set that in
our code so we will set it in the code
for it to have the true value and when
that happens we will transition from
idle to walk animation similarly right
click on the walk animation and make
transition to the idle and now we have
two arrows one pointing from idle to
walk and another from walk to idle so
click on that arrow and now I'm gonna
click on the plus button here and the
walk here is gonna be false because when
walk is true we are gonna walk when walk
is false we are gonna go back to the
idle animation now we are also going to
go from our idle to attack so click on
idle make transitions you attack and
we're also gonna make transition from a
tag back to idle so click on this
transition from idle to attack and the
condition here is going to be attack
simply this right here attack 1 because
we're gonna go from idle to attack
it's a trigger we will trigger that in
our code we will see if something is not
clear right now wait until we get to the
code part then I will have more material
to explain it more clearly to you we
will see it visually and it will be even
more clear so we are also going to go
from idle to attacked you and make
transition back so click on the
transition from idle to attack you and
the condition is going to be attacked
you don't worry about the transition
from attack to idle we will cover that
so don't worry we will cover that but
basically from attack to to idle the
transition or the parameter is going to
be when walk is equal to false same here
from attack 1 to idle that transition is
gonna be when walk is equal to false
because why would walk is equal to false
because we're also going to have from
walk to attack one and from attack one
back to walk and this transition from
walk to attack 1 is also going to have a
attack 1 trigger parameter but this
parameter here when we want to go back
from attack to walk that's when the walk
will be equal to true and similarly here
so from attack 2 back to walk and from
walk to attack you click on the
transition from walk to attack to click
on the plus button and here we are gonna
select attack to trigger and from attack
to back to the walk walk will be true
but we will do something else here as
well so don't worry about that we will
come to it we are also gonna go in our
code and then everything will be clear
now we're also going to go from idle to
defend and back from defend to idle so
when we want to go from idle to defend
that's when defend will be equal to true
so when we click here actually this
defend parameter excuse me we're gonna
delete it it's gonna be a boolean so
click here bool and defend is gonna be a
boolean parameter not a trigger so
attacks are gonna be triggers but here
we're gonna go from idle to defend when
the defend parameter is equal to true
and we are gonna go back from defend to
idle when defend is equal to false right
here now we're also gonna go from walk
to the defend and here we're gonna set
the condition defend is gonna be equal
to true but we're not gonna go back from
defense to walk we're only going to be
able to go back from defense to idle
animation now this is for setting them
up we will see them again in action we
will see them in action don't worry
about that now before we start coding
because we're gonna go here in assets
and scripts and I'm gonna right click
here and I'm going to create a new C
sharp script and this one is going to be
character animations this is where we
are going to create our animations so
this is where the animation magic is
going to happen but one thing to note is
remember those parameters that we used
now let me demonstrate that so here are
gonna have a private animator and I'm
going to call him annum and in the awake
function we are going to get a reference
to it so Adam is equal to get component
animator component voila now this is
where we are going to create our
animations and our first animation I'm
gonna delete the update function is
gonna be public void walk which takes a
bool so bull walk parameter and in order
to execute it we need to call here Adam
set bull and that bull is going to be
our walk parameter and we're going to
set the value to this walk that we pass
right here so we're going to set that
walk because we need to call it with the
name that's why we named it here if we
go here in the animator and if we go
into the parameters you see the name is
walk it's same as with find game object
with tags so it's same with tagging we
need to have the name here you see the
walk it's capital W so also here it
needs to
a capital W or otherwise it will not
work now this is what I was talking
about a minute ago before we create
these you see we have these parameters
and you know I hate hard coding so we're
gonna go here in tax now when I say I
hate hard coding there are there are
some exceptions where you will use hard
coding like this instead of creating it
here but we will see examples of that in
some other tutorial don't worry about
that so don't worry that you will never
use hard code but if you're gonna use it
often it's better to put it here in a
single script so here I'm going to
create our public class that I'm going
to call animation tax so or actually not
animations animation tag would without s
here and here we're going to have a
public constant string
this one is going to be the walk
parameter and we're going to see here
walk so the value is gonna be equal to
walk capital W so capital double u or
otherwise it will not work because the
names need to match up if here you have
a lowercase W so if here you have a
lowercase W then here as well you will
use the lowercase the point is the name
you put here for the parameter it needs
to be exactly the same name you put
right here so we also have a public
constant string defense or defend
parameter which is going to be equal to
defend like this this is the value this
is the name and we're also going to have
a public constant so it's not connection
what am I doing here
Const string and this ones are going to
be attack underscore one underscore
trigger which is gonna be equal to
attack one like this and public so it's
public constants string not public it's
public and instead of using here attack
underscore to underscore trigger because
I want to differentiate them I think it
would be better if we put them like this
so it's attack underscore trigger
underscore one
and attack underscore trigger underscore
too because I can see this 1 & 2 clearly
when there are at the end of the name 1
instead of when they are in the middle
of the variable name so now we have
everything basically and we can go here
in our character animations here for our
walk instead of using this we're simply
going to call our animation tags dot and
we're going to call the walk parameter
then here it is we are also going to
have a public void defend animation and
here are also going to have a bull
defend which is a parameter that we're
going to pass and here we're simply
going to call Adam set bull and you call
the parameter by the name so let me
explain that so animation tags that
defend parameter and here I'm going to
call defend and yes I notice here that I
did not type parameter so I need to go
back here in tags and it's the defend
parameter thank you very much you see
here I'm calling set bull because when
we created this parameter we created it
as a bull when I click on the pause
button and click Bull it's created as a
bull so you will call set bull if it's
an integer you will call set int if it's
a float set float if it's a trigger set
trigger which we will see it right now
so here we're also going to have a
public void attack underscore one and
here is simply going to call enemy set
trigger not target but set trigger and
he simply here we're going to call
animation tags so animation tags dot
attack one triggered BAM it's like that
you see set trigger and for attack - I'm
gonna duplicate this and paste it and
here instead of attack one I'm gonna say
attack two and here instead of
underscore one I'm going to say under
score two and basically that is that BAM
we are done with our animations see this
is a class and this is how I like to do
things I'd like to create a separate
class for everything and this is how
he prefers it now this is not my wisdom
I heard that I don't know what was the
name will Goldstein or that Allen guy
the guys who do official human t
tutorials I was watching one of their
tutorials and yes I watch tutorials
don't judge me I mean I'm saying don't
touch me but you should also watch other
tutorials as well anyways I heard him
saying that unity prefers that you have
a separate class for every separate test
so I want to separate my tests so here
this class will only handle animations
and now when we want to call these
animations for example the move or the
balk we simply go here in the move
script and right here below our private
character controller are going to say
private character animations and I'm
going to call this one player animations
or play your animation how you want to
say and here in the awake I'm going to
say player animations is equal to get
component character animations I'm
calling it character animations the
class name because we are also going to
attach this on our enemies now before I
animate anything I'm gonna go here in
unity and we need to attach that script
on the warrior if we don't attach it it
will not work so select the warrior
click on add component and filter for
character animations and click on that
script and hit apply so that that change
also applies to the prefab so if we go
back now in our Visual Studio so if I go
back here at the bottom I'm going to
create void animate and this is going to
animate the walk so animate walk this is
I'm going to name it so animate walk and
how are we going to animate the walk
well basically I said that the move
direction it has it is moving so it has
velocity we can test it out so we can
call here if move actually I'm saying
move direction but it's actually our
character controller so excuse me for
that one so the character controller
we're using it to move so we can test it
out so we're going to say here if our
character controller dot velocity that
square root magnitude is not equal to
zero then we are going to end
we are going to call player animations
that walk is equal to true else here
we're going to call player animations
that walk is equal to false bam bam bam
what is this while you're banging
teacher I don't know why I'm banning but
what this here is we have our character
controller and we are going to get them
a loss if you see the velocity is the
velocity speed over time if we're moving
velocity will increase over time only if
we are standing still not this is from
physics I'm not I'm not no physics guru
I just know this from looking online
it's really very simple so as I was
saying if we are moving velocity will
increase over time if we are standing
still velocity will not increase think
of it like you have a gas pedal in your
car and when you are pushing the gas
pedal to the end you know the car does
not go from one from zero to 100 in a
second no it goes slowly over time well
that slowly over time is the velocity so
if the velocity and the square root
magnitude you see this square root
magnitude and I need to do it like this
because for some reason Visual Studio is
giving me here some errors I don't know
warnings for whatever reason but let me
go here character controller so charge
controller that velocity you see the
current relative velocity of the
character meaning if he is moving or not
that the square magnitude it returns the
length of this vector because the square
root magnitude basically this velocity
is a vector value a vector has a value
of XY and z and why that because we have
speed on the XY and z axis and it will
return that speed this square root
magnitude will make that value 1 which
basically means if that value is not
equal to 0 we are moving so if that
value the velocities square root
magnitude think of the square root
magnitude simply converting this value
into a 1 so number one value if this
velocity has any value if it's zero then
it will return zero the square root
magnet
return zero if we are standing still if
we are moving we will have any value
here we will convert that value to one
which will not be equal to zero meaning
we're moving meaning we will animate the
walk meaning if we are not moving then
we will not animate the walk instead we
will animate the idle animation before
we proceed to test this out we need to
call the animate walk in the update
function so animate walk function call
it in the update function and now we are
ready to test things out so if I go back
here in unity and if I hit the play
button when I move we will see that we
are not animating now what is the reason
pay attention here to the idle animation
this blue line when this blue line
finishes now I'm gonna go to walk
animation and walk animation phrases
what the hell is going on teacher you
said that this right here will work and
why is it not working first of all let
me fix these animations so if I double
click on the idle animation here we need
to make sure that the loop time is
checked so when you select the idle if
you double click on it it will take you
here to the settings of the animation
and if you scroll a little bit down you
have this loop time which is right here
that I have circled right now this loop
time it needs to be checked because the
idle animation needs to loop and when
you check it hit apply at the bottom
left or excuse me bottom right corner
also do the same thing for the walk
selected double click it
scroll down hit the loop time and hit
apply because again the walk animation
needs to loop he needs to play over and
over and over again for us to be able to
simulate the walking and the idle
animation the event animation here so
selected for the defend animation we
will leave it for later we will see what
we're gonna do with it because we're
gonna add some extra code for that as
well so we will leave it for now these
attack animations are not going to loop
but now since these animations are
looping if I hit the play button pay
attention here in the animator you
see animations are moving you see this
blue line it means that the animation is
playing but if I try to move you see I'm
moving but you see only now the
animation is playing I don't know if you
see this and you pay attention here you
see what's going on you see here now
what is the reason for this well the
reason for this are these transitions so
we need to fix them if you select the
transition from idle to walk animation
you will notice here that we have
conditions we set the conditions to be
true that is okay but you also have
these settings here and you have the
exit time and pay attention here this
exit time transitions has a fixed exit
time and if I hover over the exit time
it will say exit time in normalized time
from current state basically this means
this exit time is how much time we have
before we exit from the animation and
usually this means that we will let that
emission to play till the end which we
saw the blue line was filling up in the
idle animation and only when the blue
line has finished filling up that's when
we transitioned to the walk animation so
in order to fix that we're gonna uncheck
the has exit time and the transition
duration we are going to say at Point 1
because we want to transition as fast as
we can from our idle to the walk
animation now in regards to the walk
animation we're gonna do the same thing
so click here the transition from walk
to idle on check has exit time fixed
duration is gonna be equal to point 1
simple like that so what about
transitions from idle to attack
basically we can test these to you how
it first so if I hit the play button now
pay attention now I'm gonna hit or now
I'm gonna start walking you see as soon
as I started walking he started to walk
you see as soon as I started to walk and
here what we need to do is the
transition or actually the condition is
false but I think in the code so else
player animations walk is equal to false
something weird is going on here because
the parameter here is ok it's false and
we
that in the animation nothing is wrong
so let me try this I'm gonna print here
and I'm gonna see the velocity is Colin
and I'm going to see plus character
controller or char controller dot
velocity dot Square Root magnitude and
I'm going to print that out to see the
value quickly see if I go here let me
just clear the console and if I hit the
play button we will see that initially
it's set to zero but now I'm gonna start
moving so now it's nine nine points so
on and so forth I'm stopping so I stop
moving whoa never saw this before
you see I'm I don't move but for some
reason the character controller still
has velocity now I'm really not sure
what is going on but let me try this let
me try to stop our character controller
instantly so basically here we're
checking if input so on and so forth if
we have input we will move our character
controller else if we don't have input
so basically here if we don't have any
input to move the character then we're
simply gonna say character controller
dot move and here we're gonna pass
vector 3 0 again vector 3 0 is a
shorthand for writing 0 0 0 for x y&z
and basically it will stop the character
controller from moving so if I go back
here in unity and clear the console and
if I hit the play button so if we go now
and if I stop then it stops see we just
need to stop it but I'm not sure why
it's not stopping on its own I'm using
the same code from the project that I
showed in the beginning it's the exact
same code I'm following that it worked
like a charm and did not use this
character controller move 0 but
basically if you have this issue this is
how you will fix it and if I get the
bottom of this issue I will create a
video talking about what the issue was
it's really interesting to see but this
is how we fixed
so yeah you need to improvise in
programming as well so this is how we
stopped our character controller to make
sure that the square root magnitude is
equal to zero
indeed so what I'm gonna do again is
testing out since we can see in action
our transition so if I walk now you see
automatically he goes from idle to walk
I'm gonna stop automatically he goes
back from walk to idle animation the
reason for that is because we edited
these transitions so we don't have the
exit time transition duration is 0
basically exit time will allow us to
finish the animation before we
transition to another animation and
transition duration is how much seconds
it will take for this transition to
happen so we set it point 1 we want to
happen as fast as possible and we saw
this in action so now things are clear
you see here we go from a low to walk
when the walk parameter is equal to true
this is what we're doing here parameter
walk is equal to true and if I go into
character animations and a set bool this
is the walk parameter we set it to this
walk parameter that we have here and we
specified that walk to be either true or
false
so if it's true it will transition from
idle to walk and if it's false it will
transition back from walk to idle and we
talked about these parameter conditions
or settings exit time fix duration so
I'm and so forth we explain what they
are and what they did and so now the
animation is a little clearer if not a
lot more clear what we are doing here
now this is in regards to the idle and
the walk animation we of course have
these trends
we need to fix but I would rather first
test it out and then we will proceed to
fix them so that we can see it in action
and make the animation concept even more
clear so for that we need to go here in
our project and scripts folder and right
click here and we are going to create a
c-sharp script that I'm going to call
player attack input and this is where
we're going to get the input for the
attack and we are going to proceed to
attack so of course we need to attach
this on our warrior character and I'm
going to hit apply and now we are going
to double click and open this script in
Visual Studio the first thing that I'm
gonna do is tag the class here at the
bottom and give a little bit of space so
that I can scroll up and down and we can
see more clearly what am i doing here so
for now the one thing that we need for
our player attack input is gonna be our
character animations and I set it to be
private because we will use getcomponent
and I'm going to name it play your
animation and inside of the awake
function so change start to awake we're
going to say player animation is equal
to get component and we're gonna get
here the character animations component
like this so what is the next thing to
do well the next thing to do is to
detect input so we need to detect input
in order to simulate the attacks and we
will simulate them with the animation so
when we press our key code let's say J
and K so when we press J we will defend
ourselves and when we press K we will
attack so here if our input gate key and
we're going to see here key code dot G
so when we press J we are going to
defend ourselves
so defend 1 J pressed and simply here we
are going to call our player animation
so we're going to say player animation
defend and here I'm going to say
because if you remember if I go back
here in unity and inside of the animator
component are actually the animator
panel you see here defend we will go
from idle to defend when the vent is
equal to true and we will go from walk
to defend when defend is equal to true
now going back here we set it to be
equal to true which means that when this
is called we will play the defend
animation now this is when the key is
pressed what we want to do what the key
is released well we want to see here if
input that get key down and this is
going to be key code so key code dot j
same key when we press it and when we
release it we are going to say here
player animation defend now he is equal
to false we will test this out in a
moment we will see some issues and we
will fix them one by one because I like
to first show you the problem and then
show you how to get the bottom of that
problem and here we're also going to say
if input get key and we are going to see
here key code K so when we press K we
are going to attack but we have two
attacks if you remember if I go back
here in unity you see here we have
attack - and we have attack 1 this is in
our animator panel so here they are
attack - and attack 1 so if I select the
warrior here and if i zoom in on him you
will see here that if I select the
attack 1 animation you see now this is
how he is attacking if I select attack -
this is how he is attacking so how can
we call these animations because I want
to randomize that and in order to
randomize it when we press our key code
K we're going to test here if our
random-dot range from 0 to 2 if it's
greater than 0 now to declare this right
here right away or actually to explain
it you see this random range will return
a random value between two numbers when
we use integers if I hover over here you
see it is using
integers if we say here F and here F it
will think that we are using floats
which you will see here when I hover
over random float as you can see random
range for a float but if I remove F and
set it to be an integer or actually just
remove F it will think we have integers
why is this important because when it
comes to integers this number here is
inclusive and this number here is
exclusive what does that mean that means
that inside of this random range it will
include this number but it will not
include this number which means
basically here it will return either 0
or 1 2 will not be returned it will
return either 0 or 1 and if we have here
for example 5 it will return 0 1 2 3 & 4
but it will not return 5 so 5 is
excluded but if they are a float so if I
see here F so 2 F + 0 F that means we
can either get 0 1 or 2 or in between
decimal point numbers so when it comes
to a float both numbers are included
when it comes to an integer then the
second number is not included which
means this will either return 0 or 1
which means 50-50 chance to perform one
attack or the second attack so here I'm
going to simply say player animation
that attack 1 and here I'm going to say
else and I'm simply going to save attack
animation too so player animation and
attack - animation and voila we are good
to go and since this is already being
called in the update function we can
safely test it out so we need to go here
in unity and pay attention now what is
going to happen so here I'm going to hit
the play button pay attention to these
animations so let's say I press K you
see I pressed K so what is happening
first of all we need to wait for our
random integer to pass and let me just
go here quickly so here I'm calling
attack 1 and here I'm calling attack 2
and in character animations so here
animations attack trigger 1 and here we
have attack
trigger - so let's go back here again
and what is going on pay attention what
is happening here so I'm gonna press it
and now we have a tattoo but again we
need to wait for the idle animation to
finish because we did not check for
these transitions and now he is
attacking and you see how much it takes
to play the attack animation so we need
to fix this and of course in order to
fix this we are going to fix the
transitions so the transition from idle
to attack one so here it's not gonna
have an exit time and for the transition
duration I'm going to see here 0.3 this
is from idle to attack 1 but when it
comes to attack 1 back to idle it's
gonna have an exit time and here the
transition duration I'm going to say
point 1 so the transition duration will
be point 1 but it will have an exit time
with the value of 1 for our transition
from idle to attack - we are not gonna
have exit time and point 3 will be that
transition duration for this transition
from attack tube back to idle we are
going to check the exit time and the
value will be 1 and here the transition
duration will be equal to 1 now when it
comes from our attack or from walk to
the attack animation so this one right
here to attack 1 uncheck exit time point
3 for the transition duration going back
here from attack 1 to walk we are not
gonna have her actually exit time is
going to be 1 and transition duration is
going to be equal to 6 and then
similarly here from walk to attack -
we're not gonna have an exit time but
0.3 for the transition duration and for
our other transition same as with from
attack 1 to walk we will use the same
thing for attack 2 to walk so exit time
will be 1 and transition duration will
be 0.6 and for our defense so we are
also going to fix defend now because it
will have the same issue people have the
same issue as we just saw so
we are going to see here uncheck exit
time and 0.3 for our transition duration
we're going to do the same exact thing
here from walk to defend so uncheck exit
time 0.3 for transition duration and
going back from defense to the idle
animation 1 for the exit time point 6
for the transition duration so now let's
test it out and see what we have here so
if I go and test it out again so pay
attention now did you see I don't know
if you see here that we are attacking
with 2 we attack just you what is you
see here I just pressed the number I
just pressed it once you see I press the
animation only once as you can see here
so again but it's attacking multiple
times you see here now I'm not even
pressing a button now you're like ok
teacher do you know what you're doing I
do know what I'm doing but I want to
show you so let's go back here what is
the problem the problem is here get key
so we should not use get key because get
key returns true while the user holds
down the key basically when we press and
when we hold a kena of course I did not
hold the key what I did is I simply I
simply pressed it but since this is
called in the update function which is
run every frame in a second it can
happen that I held unintentionally four
to three frames while I press the button
is what it was basically held in quotes
and those two three frames caught that
and it is called that many times so what
we need we only need to detect when we
press down the button and basically for
that we are gonna say get key down so
you see here get key down this is what
we need and here also we're gonna say
get key down and here we're gonna say
get key up I wanted to write it before
but for some reason I wrote down get key
down will detect when you press the
button only once so when you press it
and even if you hold it it will detect
that only once get key up it will detect
when you
release the pressed key we're gonna use
this when we press this right here we're
gonna hold the shield and when we
release it then we will release or lower
down the shield now that we are using
gate key down let's go here and let's
test it I'll see if I hit here the play
button so if I hit the play button pay
attention out so if I press the key you
see now automatically only one time it
is executed and only one time we go into
the animation now one thing that you're
noticing is that the animation is very
slow so you see now is like a slow
motion when he attacks you saw that in
order to fix that you're simply going to
select and let me just go here take the
highlight tool so you're gonna click on
the animation right here the motion
State that is and right here you have
the speed of that animation so it's
right here where I'm pointing and for
attack one we're gonna say the speed is
going to be four and for attack - we're
gonna say the speed is three that means
it will run four times as faster than
its original speed and this one the
other one will run three times faster
than its original speed basically so
this is what we are saying so now if I
test it out so if I go here and hit the
play button if I press you see now how
fast it is so it's playing these
animations fast we are transitioning
from one animation to another fast you
see everything is basically working now
you see and you can see here inside of
the animator the animations that are
being played so when I press here
automatically goes to attacked you when
it finishes it go back to idle so on and
so forth when I press the shield you see
he is holding his hand but I also
released the button so if I press it and
hold it you see now he also gets back we
need to fix this now in order for you to
understand what I just said we are going
to import the shield and the Swart so if
I go here in models and here we have our
weapon so here is our weapon this one
here did I imported enough for some
reason I did not so basically this is
our weapon this right here and the
weapon I'm going to call it sward and
we're going to click on the warrior
drop-down list then VIP object and
pelvis here then spine then spine one
spine to the neck then a right clavicle
upper arm I know this is tedious and
here is our right hand this is where we
are going to position height our shield
on the right hand what you can do is you
can type our hand and here it is so this
one right here the our hand and you're
gonna select this word and for the
position here X I'm going to say
negative zero point zero three eight
nine for the position Y I'm gonna say
zero point zero one two eight and for
the Z I'm gonna say zero point zero zero
three four now the rotation X is going
to be negative negative one to seven the
rotation was going to be equal to
negative 100 and the rotation Z is going
to be negative 1 or 4 so negative 104
basically that is that this is how we
are going to hold our sward as you see
right here now for the shield so we're
gonna go back in models and now we have
shields and here it is and I'm going to
rename it to shield this one is going to
be positioned under the left hand so
simply type here el hand and here it is
when I say type here I mean right here
in the hierarchy search tab so this one
right here you simply type el hand and
here it is this sounds like some I don't
know some Schwartzman el hand anyways
take the shield and attach it here on
the el hand and let me just reposition
it so for the x position is gonna be
0.04 t 1 for the Y it's going to be
negative 0.008 for the Z it's going to
be negative 0.005 and the rotation 98
for the X for the Y 81 for the z
it's gonna be 180 and basically that is
that so this is our shield and this is
our sport again pause the video here if
you want to copy these exact values
where the shield is positioned and as
you can assume when I was preparing this
project I have positioned as
experimented moving it up down left and
right until I got it to the place where
or to the position where I want it to be
and basically now we have our shield and
we have our sward now let me select the
sport and you can also pause the video
for this more so if you want to position
it so this is where we can position our
sport and voila this is it so now if I
go and test this out you will see this
in action way better so now we have the
sward if you see we are holding the
sward and if I press the key you see now
we are attacking with the sward we are
stabbing come on stab okay he stabbed
and stabbed pay attention now if I hit
this for the shield you see he simply
holds it up and lowered sit down if I
hit the J key and hold it you see again
he plays that animation and now you see
what is happening here the animation is
not working basically now the reason for
that is if I select the warrior and go
to the defense 0-1 animation this is
that animation this is how the full
animation looks like you see this right
here he basically puts that shield up
and then he lowered it down in the same
animation what we need to do is we need
to freeze that animation where we are
somewhere around here so at the middle
approximately or frame I don't know
frame 30 frame whatever
so basically when we are here somewhere
something like this this is where we are
going to freeze the animation so that it
stops and in order to do that we need to
go back in visual studio and inside of
the character animations right here at
the bottom below our attack - we're
going to create here void freeze
animation and not free but freeze so
it's freeze animation like this
and here are simply going to see and
that speed is equal to zero now setting
the speed of the animator and an M is
our animator if we set the speed to zero
that means we will basically turn it off
shut it down it will not move the speed
is zero and in order to turn it back or
make it work like normal so we're going
to say public void on freeze animation
and here since we are unfreezing we are
going to say an M speed is equal to 1
again so 0 and 1 is the speed for the
animation 0 stopping the animation
completely so stopping that animation
completely and again for our freezing we
are going to set 0 and voila we are good
to go
now this freeze animation we are going
to call inside of this animation right
here we're going to use animation events
now you see this animation that we have
imported so I'm gonna see here clear you
see this animation defense it's
read-only if you pay attention here it
says read only read only means that we
can only display this animation we
cannot edit this animation in any way we
cannot delete these steps for the
animation see we cannot right click and
remove properties I cannot add any
animation events right here and in order
to do that what we need to do is locate
this animation so the fence 0 here it is
it's inside of the models an animation
defense underscore 0 and this is an
animation clip so we want the animation
clip which is inside of this game object
you see here that I've circled but this
is the clip that we want you see this
defense underscore 0 what you're gonna
do is you're going to take this clip and
you're going to hold command on Mac on
Windows you're going to hold control and
you're going to press D this will
duplicate it so now we have an
independent defense animation is you can
see right here we have an independent
defense animation what does it mean to
be
independent well it means that our
animation is not dependent on this one
right here on this defense that we have
imported and we're going to rename it to
defense animation and now I'm also going
to check this loop time right here so
pay attention when you click on this
defense animation you will have a loop
time here check it because we want the
loop time to be checked and if I go here
in animator and select the defend
animation what I'm gonna do is change
the motion here for the clip so this
right here exactly where this is
pointing so this one I'm going to click
on this little circle right here and
filter for our defense
animation so click here defense
animation here it is now because it's
independent it's not read-only if I
select it here it's not read-only
anymore it's basically now we can edit
it so we can hit here the recording
button we can add more to this animation
so on and so forth but this means that
we can press this button notice this and
actually not this right here so clear
you see this right here that I've just
circled inside of the animation tab that
is called
an animation event keyframe so I can go
for example here and let's say I don't
know at frame 20 exactly here I want to
add an animation event so I'm gonna
click on that button that I just showed
you this one right here that you see so
click on it when you click on it and let
me just hide the highlight tool so when
you click on it you will see now that in
the inspector panel first of all you
will see here at that frame you see this
blue line that's the animation event and
when you click on it you see the
properties here in the inspector panel
basically this is a drop-down list that
we can click here and we can select
which one of these functions we want to
be executed when we hit this frame so
when we hit this frame and go over this
animation event inside of this animation
so I want to freeze that animation so
I'm gonna click here and select freeze
animation so now when we play this
animation and we get to this point right
here it will hit or pass on this enemy
which has this function here and this
function is right here inside of our
character animation script so it will
execute this function and in order to
unfreeze the animation we need to go in
our attack input and right here key code
up we need to call here player animation
that unfreeze animation in order for
this to work so here we are gonna
unfreeze because inside of this
animation we are freezing it and our
animator does not work so in order for
this to work we need to unfreeze the
animation and make the animator work
like normal so if I go here and hit the
play button pay attention now if I hold
press and hold the Kiko J you see now he
is holding you see now he is holding his
shield you see he is basically holding
if I release the button he releases the
shield and this is how we can see this
way better so I'm gonna go here in the
scene and here is our player he's
playing his idle animation so pay
attention on the scene view I'm gonna
press J you see he is holding the shield
and I'm pressing the G key and holding
it I'm currently holding it and now I
have released it and he released that
animation so basically we simulated this
with our animation and with our code
again what we did is in our character
animation we froze that so we are
calling freeze animation which will be
called at this exact frame so defense
animation and this frame right here it
will be called so this is the frame
right here and it will be called in that
frame it will go inside of the script
which has this freeze animation
functions will execute here and in our
player attack when we release the key so
get key up the penguin GA is pressed
down and here I'm going to say release
the fence when J is released so when J
key is released so when we release it we
unfreeze the animation
and set the defense animation to false
to go back to the idle animation and now
we can finally create our enemy because
we have all the ingredients basically
our enemy is going to be the duplicate
of our player so what I'm gonna do here
is duplicate the warrior and I'm going
to change him to so his name actually to
enemy so now we have the enemy name here
we are not gonna have the character
controller so you're gonna remove that
we are also going to remove player move
script and player attack input the only
thing that we are going to leave here is
the character animations now we are also
going to have a box Collider so attach a
box Collider on the enemy but what I'm
gonna do is I am going to take the enemy
and move him here so right here and I'm
going to rotate him 180 degrees on the
Y's so that he is facing the player
basically as you can see right there the
enemy is over there you can see him so
now let me first edit this boss Collider
because it's not in place so for the Y
position of the Box Collider or the
offset it's going to be point 92 Z we
are not going to touch as you can see
I'm editing these right here so the
Center for the Y's point ninety two the
size X is going to be point twenty eight
the size Y is going to be one point
eighty one and the size Z is going to be
point thirty four and voila this is our
Collider right now I'm also going to
take the character animation and move it
right here below our box Collider yes
continue break the prefab I don't care
because we're gonna go here into
navigation now what is this navigation
what is this right here
well this navigation is first of all you
can located here under window and then
8i and the navigation and probably this
tab will be floating like this so it
will be floating I'm gonna dock it right
here where my inspector panel is and
what you're gonna do inside of this
is that we are going to bake our areas
bake the objects that we are basically
going to use for navigation so if I go
on the fourth tab here so pencil and
clear you see the fourth tab which is
object when you select that then you
click on this right here mesh renderers
so select on that click there and you
see all of these game objects so we're
going to select all of these draw calls
and the ground and we're not gonna
select anything else so all of these and
the ground basically I'm going to click
here navigation static and I'm going to
say walkable but for these draw calls
let me select them and uncheck that and
navigate actually navigation static but
not walkable so these are going to be
not walkable and the ground is going to
be walkable the word says its self so
it's self explainatory basically
walkable means we can walk on it who
will be able to navigate on it and not
walkable is none or not walkable so all
of these draw calls they're going to be
not walkable click first navigation
static and then not walkable then click
on the ground which is our cube which is
where our game objects are standing
which is our battlefield and navigation
static and then walkable so when you do
that this is how you denote to unities
AI system or the navigation that we can
walk on these areas basically these are
not walkable so it will avoid them but
these that are walkable we can walk on
them and I'm going to go now in the bake
tab right next to the object tab we have
the bake tab and simply click here bake
at the bottom right corner when you
click on that BAM unity will do its
thing and you see here these blue lines
or this is light blue or light green I
don't know what this color is so don't
judge me anyways this what has this
color this light blue or a green this
means that it is navigation of all we
can walk on these but those that don't
have for example like this right here
this is not navigational and we cannot
walk on these areas why is this
important so now I'm gonna go back in
the inspector panel
and cleared this tea mesh from the
search this is important because now we
can select our enemy and I can attach
another component which is the nav mesh
agent so I'm gonna click Add component
and nav mesh agent attach it
remove the character script or actually
move it down and this is our nav mesh
agent now here for the angular speed I'm
going to set it 800 this is basically
the rotation speed of the enemy how fast
he will rotate so this is the only thing
that I'm gonna change so how fast he
will rotate now that we have the enemy
and we have baked the walkable areas we
attach the nav mesh agent I'm gonna go
inside the scripts folder and right
click here and I'm going to create a new
c-sharp script and this one is going to
be our enemy controller so I'm going to
call it enemy so come on enemy
controller and select the enemy game
object itself so select it and drag and
drop the enemy controller on the enemy
now before we continue let's go here in
the prefabs and drag-and-drop the enemy
prefab right here inside of the prefabs
folder and now we can go here in enemy
and I can double-click this enemy
controller script and I can open it in
visual studio let me just tag the class
here and voila yeah of course why not
why should not Visual Studio give me
these red errors again it's been open
too much this happen already so I need
to close it and I need to reload it or
open it again
for this to work for some reason it
happens like this sometimes so I don't
know why don't tell don't ask me because
I don't know anyways in order for us to
use the nav mesh agent we need to see
here using unity engine that AI which is
well where our nav mesh agent is located
a is for artificial intelligence I'm
also going to create here a public enum
that I'm going to call enemy state and
inside of this public enum I'm going to
create two staked we are all either
going to have the chase state or the
State so either chase or the attack now
here inside of our enemy controller
right here right below that is we are
going to have a reference to a private
character animation which I'm going to
call enemy annum so enemy Adam
underscore Adam we are also going to
have a private nav mesh agent which is
the nav agent that we have attached he
is going to help us navigate and we will
see that in a second
so nav mesh agent which I'm going to
call nav agent we are also going to have
a private transform which is going to be
our player target we are also going to
have a public float move under square
speed which is going to be equal to
three point five this is the movement
speed of our nav mesh agent we are also
going to have a public float attack
distance of attack underscore distance
which is going to be equal to one-half
now this attack distance is the distance
how close can we get to our player
before we start to attack basically how
close we get to the player before we
start attacking so attack distance
public float chase after attack distance
which is going to be equal to one F and
is going to be chase underscore player
so chase player after attack basically
if we attack and after that attack the
player decides to run this is going to
be the distance we will allow him to run
before we start attacking or chasing him
we will see that don't worry we are also
going to have a private float wait
before attack time which is going to be
equal to three this is how many seconds
we're gonna wait before we attack we
will see this in a second and our
private float attack timer and this one
is going to denote when we start or when
should we attack and of course we also
need this enemy state so here I'm going
to create a private enemy state which
I'm going to call enemy underscore
underscore state like this
so now inside of the awake function so
awake change start to awake we need to
get ourselves some references first of
all we are going to get our enemy Adam
so enemy Adam is going to be equal to
get component character animations and
we're also going to get the nav agent
which is going to be he could to get
component nav mesh agent we are also
going to get our player so we're going
to say player target is going to be
equal to your game object find the game
object with the tag tags that player tag
dot transform to get the player and this
is what we need for now inside of the
start function so right here in the
start so create the start function
inside of the start function we are
going to set the enemy state to be equal
to enemy state chase and our attack
timer is going to be equal to you wait
before attack time now in order to
understand this we need to create two
functions so right here we're going to
create the void chase play here like
this
chase player and right below we're going
to create void attack player like this
and in the update function if the enemy
sub enemy
state enemy underscore state is equal to
enemy state chase so if it's equal to
the chase we're going to chase the
player if our enemy underscore states of
underscore come on here enemy underscore
state is equal to you enemy state attack
then we are going to attack our player
like this so we're going to attack him
okay now let's count it out don't worry
when I code this out I will realize the
code again and it will be very clear
what is happening so as you can see here
in our chase we are gonna say nav agent
set destination so set the destination
come on man
the nation play your target that
position what the hell is this you see
set destination is the sets or updates
the destination triggering their
calculation for a new path basically the
destination where the nav agent should
go will be our players position this is
the destination nav agent that speed is
going to be equal to move speed so this
is the speed of the nav agent that we
are going to use and if our nav agent
velocity that square root magnitude is
equal to zero then we are going to see
enemy annum dot walk and we're going to
see here false and this is basically the
same thing as with our player else
except here we will not have those
issues that we have with that we had
actually with our players so here we
have now true and right here below we
are going to test if our vector3
distance between the transform dot
position which is the current position
of the enemy and our player target that
position if that is less than or equal
to the attack distance meaning we are in
the distance where we can attack enemy
state he is going to be equal to your
enemy state attack basically we can test
this out because we set here the enemy
state to chase and here we are going to
set this to chase so we can explain this
right here if I go in unity and if I
take my warrior so I'm gonna take the
warrior and I'm gonna move him a little
bit here so a little bit away from the
enemy and before we test this out if you
remember we created the enemy by
duplicating the player so what you need
to do is select the enemy and make sure
that the player tag is not selected
because if we go back here in our script
we will get the player target by using
the fine game object with the tag so tag
player it will search for that same tag
so you need to be careful with this so
select the enemy and go here and I'm
going to click on add tag and click on
the plus button and create an enemy tag
and select the enemy and tag the enemy
the enemy tagged and I'm going to hit
apply button so be careful with this
because we're using the code here we're
using find game object with the tag
player tag and it will be confused if it
has two tags and it only needs to find
one if it's find game objects with the
tag then it will get the array of game
objects who have that tag player but
when we are searching only for one and
we have two in the scene then unity will
be confused and your code will be broken
so you need to pay attention for that so
if I hit the play button now and go back
here in the scene view you will see how
the enemy is coming closer to the player
you see he is going towards the player
when he gets where the player is so
basically he needs to stop here but we
did not tell him to stop he goes here
where the player is in voila that is
that let me just see here if I take the
player and if I position here no he
arrived at his destination and that is
where the path ends I thought that if I
move the player he will Bree reevaluate
his destination but no we need to do
that through code but let me explain
what happened here basically let's go
from the top this right here is our
character animations in the nav mesh
agent that we are using so this is clear
this is the transform of the player this
is the move speed of our nav agent this
is the attack distance and chase player
after attack distance we will see this
in more depth when we create our attack
so don't worry for these two but what is
going on here is that we are getting our
component character animations we are
getting the component nav agent and also
we created here these states by the way
chase an attack and we set the state
enemy by default to be chase and here in
the update if the state is equal to
chase then we will chase the player and
when that happens we are going to go
inside of this function so what does
this function do basically you see this
function here will set the destination
meaning the target where should the nav
agent go because the nav agent you see
this one right here that we have
attached on our enemies
the enemy you see the nav mesh agent he
is the one who knows how to navigate on
these green lines are these this green
light green area because we bake that
using unities navigation all of that
information is available to our nav
agent he knows how to navigate in this
area and for it to navigate so for the
nav agent to go towards a certain
position we need to call so we need to
call here set the destination so nav
agent set its destination to the
position where we want to go we want to
go towards the player so where the
player is this is where we want to go
this is our destination and here we set
the speed to the movement speed so move
speeds so that we can move by the speed
that we added right here which will set
the speed of the nav agent while going
towards this destination now you see
here our nav agent as if I run the game
again and if I click here on the scene
you see how the enemy is coming closer
to the player so our nav agent has
velocity built in side of it and we
talked about velocity its speed over
time and I said the example when you
press your gas pedal on your car your
car does not go from zero to 100 and one
second it goes slowly so while you're
holding the gas pedal it goes from 10 20
30 40 up to 100 speed that's that is
velocity it increases over time
basically if the nav agent is moving the
velocity has a value and square root
magnitude will simply set it to a number
meaning if that number is greater than
zero so if it's equal to zero basically
that means we are not moving so if the
velocities square root magnitude is
equal to zero we are not moving which
means we're not going to animate the
walk animation else if the square root
magnitude is not equal to zero meaning
it's greater than zero meaning we are
moving then we will set the walk to true
and we saw that we're animating
and so I'm not going to go back but we
saw that in action so the next thing
here that we have is our vector three
distance and this this measures the
distance between two points basically
here I'm measuring the distance between
the transform position which is the
current enemy's position and between the
players position so think of it like
this actually here is my highlight tool
think of it like this if the enemy is
here and the player is here I am
measuring this distance between them so
this distance between them will be
measured and we will check if that
distance is a less than or equal to the
attack distance so if the distance again
between the enemy and the player if that
distance is lower or equal to the attack
distance we are in the range where we
can attack then we are going to call
here enemy state change it to the attack
state which will make this true so if
the enemy state is equal to attack we
will call the attack function player now
inside of this function here what's
gonna happen we need to stop our nav
mesh agent you saw that he reached where
the player is and he was moving
basically so let's do that again just to
test it out to see what I'm talking
about so he will reach where the
player's destination is you see here he
is going towards a player going going
going he gets where the player is and he
stops but basically he's not moving but
he is playing the Move animation we
don't want that what we need to do here
is we need to call nav agent that
velocity is equal to vector 3 0 this
will completely stop our nav mesh agent
it will make him stop in an instance
basically this is like your apply
instant break on your car and it breaks
instantly it does not move an inch
after that we're also going to say nav
agent is stopped is equal to true
basically this will stop nav agent nav
agent is now not working when we type
here is stop and if I hover over it will
say the property holds the stop or
resume can
addition for the nav agent even here if
we set the destination but if we call
here is stop so if I say nav agent is
stopped and equal to true it won't stop
it will not try to go to this
destination because it is it has
instructions to stop so now we stopped
dot Navigant by these two lines of code
the next thing to do is call our enemy
walk or enemy and and walk is now equal
to false our attack timer plus equals to
time dot delta time and if our attack
timer is greater than wait so wait
before attack time this is where we
attack and again we have to attack so we
are going to say if random that range
from zero to two he is greater than zero
50-50 chance that you are going to
attack with attack one or attacked you
so here is simply going to say enemy
Adam dot attack one else so not here
enemy Adam but else else attack to voila
and we need to reset here the attack
timer so attack timer is equal to zero
so that we can basically attack again
now we can test this out but we also
need to start chasing the player if we
can attack because the player can move
away from us this right here will stop
the game object will stop it let me test
it out and see that for yourself so if I
hit the play button now let me just try
to move a little bit closer to our enemy
so come on just move a little bit closer
go here into the scene so pay attention
now the enemy will stop near the player
so it will stop and it will start
attacking you see it starts to attack
but if we run away we run away and voila
this is that you see but the enemy will
continue attacking here does not know
that we went so we need to tell it that
so we basically need to tell our enemy
that we run away so going back here
right below this if statement we need to
test if our vector3 distance again the
distance from the enemy
transform.position
and the distance from our player target
position if it's greater than the attack
distance Plus chase player after attack
so if this is true then we're gonna call
nav agent is stopped is false
enabling nav agent to move and any state
is gonna be equal to enemy state chase
and we can start chasing our player so
what is going on here basically we saw
that the enemy was coming towards the
player we explained that right here we
explain what is going on setting the nav
agent destination towards the player
will make the nav agent move towards the
player this is the speed here we are
testing if we are moving we will animate
if the distance is lower or equal to the
attack distance then we will attack this
happens when we attack we stop the nav
agent from moving we tell him UART stop
don't use nav agent at that time we set
the walk to false and now we trigger
these attack timers
you saw that in the start function here
I said the attack timer to be equal to
wait before attack time and here I'm
adding to the attack timer Delta time
and when the attack timer has a value
greater than wait before attack time we
will attack basically this is that when
we go here and let me just bring the
player closer to the enemy so now pay
attention when the player gets as close
to the enemy he starts attacking right
away so that is that first attack and
now he waits you see he waits a little
bit then attacks again basically this
right here because we said the attack
timer to equal to wait before attack
time as soon as we add here timed out
Delta time did the attack timer it will
have a value greater than wait before
attack time because again we set it here
we set that here to be equal to so when
we add a little bit value to it it is
greater which means we can attack I want
to simulate that because as soon as we
get close to the player
I want the enemy to
attack the player that's why it happened
like that and then we reset the attack
timer to zero if we don't call this if I
remove this from here and if I go back
basically let me just turn this off I'm
telling now the word basically too much
I don't know for some reason let me just
take the warrior and move him a little
bit closer to the enemies so that we can
test this out faster so if I take the
scene view and as soon as the enemy
comes here he will attack once and since
we are not resetting the attack time you
see what is happening basically he is
attacking every second now the reason
for that is because the attack timer
will always have a value greater than
wait before attack time if we don't
reset it back to zero so now we are
going to reset it back to zero which
will wait this many seconds that we
specified right here so now you
understand these variables we wait this
many seconds three that we specified
here before we can attack and we're
adding time now Delta time to the attack
timer so that eventually it will have a
value greater than wait before attack
time and this is what we are doing here
and basically when we attack again with
the word basically so after that when
this is true we will test the random
range between zero and two if it's
greater than zero we will attack with
the attack one if it's not greater than
0 then we will attack with the attack
two same as what we did with our player
randomizing the attack and we explain
this so now we are coming close to this
you see vector three distance transform
position so if the distance between the
enemy and the player is greater than the
attack distance which is this one right
here so this is the attack distance Plus
this distance right here so if it's
greater the untagged distance Plus this
here we're gonna give just a little
space for the player so that he can run
away before we start chasing him and we
can see that right here so first of all
let me take the enemy and I'm going to
set the attack distance and one point
three because and I'm gonna hit apply to
apply that change to the prefab because
I don't want the enemy to come that
close to the place
or he can come at 1.3 distance which is
this distance right here you will see
now you see this right here is exactly
enough and this is how it looks like in
our game view and basically you can play
with this attack again with the word
basically you can play with this attack
distance value so the higher the number
then the enemy will be far away from the
player before he starts attacking but
pay attention now when I start to run
away you see he will wait a moment or
two before he starts chasing me so he
will wait the attack distance plus this
cheese after attack distance until he
starts to chase and here we need to say
NAB agent is stop is false because here
we set it to be equal to true which will
stop the NAB agent so set it to true
will stop it if we don't call here this
so if we don't call now its equal to
false to tell the NAB agent that he is
not stopped anymore pay attention what
will happen so if I hit here the play
button and the enemy will come close to
me
so you will come close now he will start
attacking but if I try to run away you
see he is not following me because he is
stopped you see nothing is happening
because we need to tell the nav agent is
top now is false because again here we
set it to be true and now we are telling
him you are not stopped anymore
you can move and he will start moving
and then we simply set the enemy States
to chase which again will make this
right here true which will call the
chase player function this will locate
where the player is setting the
destination to the player's position
setting the speed to the nav agent and
moving the netnavi agent animating him
all of this stuff that we already
explained and we are basically reusing
these two functions one after another
and here if we get again close to the
player then we will say state his attack
which will make this true and it will
execute the attack player function and
we explained everything what is
happening in the player attack function
so basically we are going from one
function to another chasing the player
then attacking if he runs away we chase
him again
and again with the word basically I
don't know what's wrong with me so when
he runs away we start chasing again when
we get close we start attacking again so
what is the next step to do because we
are attacking but we are not dealing
damage and we are not detecting that
attack let's fix that so go back in
unity and select the warrior here in the
scene I'm gonna zoom in on him on him
and click on this word
so this is our sward for the player and
I am going to right-click on the sward
game object itself and create an empty
game object this one is going to be the
attack point and I'm going to tag this
attack point with let's say this orange
colors that I can move it and let's say
somewhere around here I think it's okay
so this is where it's going to be at
zero point zero zero one eight eight for
the y-axis just move him a little bit
here and basically that is that so this
is where the attack point is going to be
for our warrior and of course for our
enemy is going to be at the same exact
place so let me just select the enemy
here click on it sward and right-click
on the sword and create an empty this is
going to be at the attack point for the
enemy and let me just copy this position
so zero point zero zero one nine five
nine for the y-axis and bam and I can
also tag it here with the red color so
that we can see where it is so we see
them both so we see the orange one and
we see the red one for the player and
for the enemy respectively what is the
next thing to do the next thing to do is
right-click here in side of our scripts
folder and create a new c-sharp script
and I'm going to call this one attack
damage and of course as you can assume
we are going to attach this on the
attack point so select both of these
attack points and go here and filter for
the attack
script and basically wallah so now I'm
gonna double-click on the attack damage
and here it is so what we're gonna do
here is we're going to detect that
collision what we need for that
collision well we need here public layer
mask which I'm going to call layer we
also need a public float the radius
which is going to be equal to by default
one notice it's public we can edit this
in the inspector panel we also need the
public float damage to deal damage and
that by default I'm gonna set to be
equal to one of course because it's
public we can change the value in the
inspector panel we don't need the start
function for this one we only need the
update and inside of the update we are
going to say here Collider array which
I'm going to call hits is gonna be equal
to physics overlap sphere at the
transform position using the radius
using that layer that we have provided
what the hell is going on you see this
physics overlap sphere it is going to
overlap a sphere at this position with
this radius in this layer basically this
is the following so if I go here come on
what are you doing to me so here is the
warrior I'm gonna zoom on the warrior we
see where the point is so we see where
the point is here it is this orange
thing if I take the animation of the
warrior and let's say at AG zero and
point or actually pay attention here I
wanted to say pay attention at point
actually attacked you because attacked
you you see it's like this he he moves
the hand behind him and then he attacks
this overlap sphere will create a sphere
at that position because we attached
this on the attack point that sphere
will be created on this position where
the attack point is so it will be
created like this think of it like this
this is my highlight tool here so it
will overlap a sphere and this position
will create a sphere like this it's
Terkel think of it as a circle it will
create that circle at this position this
is the radius of the circle you know
circles have radius so the larger the
radius the bigger the circle is and this
layer right here means that the circle
will search for collisions with game
objects that are put on this layer right
here now what the hell is this layer
this layer is this one right here so if
I go here and let me just clear the
pencil this is the layer you see here at
the hierarchy for every game object you
have this layer all game objects are set
on a default layer by default when you
create them and that layer can be used
for collision detection so we can do
things like this right here we can check
here in the code if we are colliding
with a game object that is on that layer
we can even exclude collisions between
layers with all the layer option so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna select the
warrior let me just pull this we're
gonna select the warrior and we're gonna
go under layer and we're gonna click on
this add layer now this is a drop-down
list your click on when you click on the
layer you have the default ones that are
created automatically by unity but we
need our own so I'm gonna click here on
add layer and here I'm gonna create two
new ones one is going to be the player
another one is going to be the enemy
so if I select the warrior and click
here and we're gonna select the player
and you see this will pop up do you want
to set the layer for all child game
objects no only for the parent we don't
want these children game objects we
don't want the them to have the player
layer because the warrior the player he
is important so we're gonna do the same
thing for the enemy click here and
select the enemy layer now know this
object only hit apply here hit apply
here now what is beautiful here is that
we can because here in our code we are
searching here for collision with the
game object that is put on this layer
right here you see on this layer right
here so what we are gonna do is we are
simply going to select the attack point
for the player and we're going to search
for the collision
on the enemy lair because the player is
attacking the enemy and I'm gonna hit
apply to make that change apply to the
prefab and here for the enemy I'm going
to click on these fold or how are these
are call these arrows and select the
attack points for the enemy and we're
gonna search for collision on the player
layer and click apply so that that
change applies to the prefab because
when we attack with the enemy we are
attacking the player so we need to
search for collisions with the player or
for the player layer and here we are
searching for collisions with the enemy
layer now how can we know if we have
collisions well simply simply here
because this overlap sphere returns an
array of hits or array of colliders if
we test here if our hits that length is
greater than 0 that means we at least
have one hit meaning we at least touched
one game object so at least one game
object is touched with this over lab
sphere if the length of the array is
greater than 0 and here simply we are
going to say print and I'm going to say
touched the game object and basically we
can test this out right now
so if I go here in the console and clear
everything so clear from the console if
I go and try to attack even if the enemy
attacks me now so pay attention in the
console what will happen you see we are
printing this too much you see it's
printed like 300 times you see it here
in the console we need to limit this so
we need to limit this well how can we
limit when we touch our game object we
can simply see here gameobject.setactive
he is equal to false and this is how we
can deactivate the attack point but this
will create another issue because again
we are dealing damage here remember here
we are dealing damage here we are gonna
get the health script and gonna apply
that damage and you saw it was called
300 times in a second so the reason for
that is because the game object is
in the scene what will happen now is the
following when I go here and when we
attack pay attention so only once or
actually it managed to attack me two
times or actually no I attacked him once
so yeah mine was also triggered and
enemy was also triggered but now we are
not detecting collision between each
other anymore
so we need a better solution but by now
I hope that you get the point why we
need to deactivate this game object the
reason for that is if we leave it open
if we leave it on or actually leave it
active you saw that it is every time it
touches or detects that collision it
will execute the code and here are gonna
do this we're gonna say hits and the
element that's it index zero that
getcomponent and we're gonna get the
health script component and we're gonna
see here apply damage and we're gonna
pass the damage for the float now we did
not create this but we will create it
and this is going to apply damage to our
game objects and if we allow it to apply
that damage 300 times as we saw a moment
ago then we cannot play our game our
players will die instantly so what we
need to do is select these attack points
and turn them off so turn one attack
point off turn another attack point off
and for our warrior so starting with the
warrior what I'm gonna do is go here in
the player attack input and right here
right here below our character animation
so below the character animation what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna create a
public game object which is going to be
the attack point and at the bottom here
I'm going to say void activate
underscore attack point and I'm gonna
say here attack point set active is true
to activate that attack point and below
I'm gonna say void deactivate underscore
attack point and simply here I'm gonna
say attack point set active is equal to
false or set it to false but one thing
to note here is because we are
deactivating here there is a chance
we will deactivate this game object
before it's even deactivated here
because notice what we're gonna do here
we're gonna test if our attack points Oh
attack point is active in hierarchy so
if the attack point is active in the
hierarchy then we will deactivate it the
reason for that is because we're gonna
go now and we're gonna take these two
animations so we're gonna take the
attack zero one and attack zero two or
actually attack hunter score zero so
click it here here it is
attack underscore zero and duplicate it
and attack underscore one and duplicate
it so I'm gonna take the attack is going
to be attack two and this one is going
to be attack one so I'm going to name
them attack one and attack two and go
back in the animator and select this
right here and change the motion Ord
animation clip from a tag zero to attack
one and for the attack to do the same
thing except here are gonna select
attack two because you can assume why we
already did this a moment ago we're
gonna go in our animation tab right here
and for the attack one so I'm gonna
preview it so this is how it looks like
and here I'm going to click on this
animation event and I'm going to select
to activate so activate the attack point
and when it attacks so somewhere around
here I'm going to click another
animation event and I'm going to type
here deactivate the attack point and for
our attack two animation I'm gonna do
the same thing for so so somewhere
around here here this is where the
attack will go or this is where the
animation will get and I'm going to call
here activate attack point and when it
gets here I'm going to call another
animation event and I'm going to say
here deactivate attack point so you get
my point
so do you get what I why I'm doing this
here because if we attack and we don't
hit a player
if we get a hit here for the player or
for the enemy then we will deactivate
the game object but if we attack and we
don't get collisions here then when the
animation finishes let me go here play
or attack input when the animation
finishes then we will
as you can see deactivate these attack
points and we're gonna copy these two
scripts and go inside of the enemy
controller and here right below the
enemy State I'm gonna say public game
object attack point so declaring the
attack point and going here at the
bottom so right above the class
declaration and calling these two
functions and we don't have to do
anything for the enemy because the enemy
has the same animations we're using the
same animator controller for the enemy
and for the player so if we go here we
have the attack as you can see it has
the exact same effect what what is left
for us to do is select the warrior and
drag and drop his attack point here
inside of the player attack input sorry
I bugged there for a second so play your
attack input and for our enemies select
the enemy and here for the enemy
controller drag and drop the attack
point in the attack point and hit apply
so that these changes apply it to the
prefab and basically we are done we can
now test things out and I will explain
them again so let's go here in the
console and see how things goes how
things go how things go notice now if I
attack so I'm attacking the point is
being activated but we are not hitting
the enemy so now you see and then let me
attack me but now you see why is this
here necessary the reason for that is
because you saw I attacked the enemy was
not there we activated the attack point
but we did not have any hit we didn't
have any hit here so this will not be
executed it will not hit this line of
code so game objects and active Falls
will never be called meaning when we get
to the animation frame where we call
this then if the attack point is active
this right
here we'll test if it's active meaning
we did not call set active or it's
basically active if I select the ground
and if I click here this is now not
active you see when I click on this
checkbox which is right here you see
where the check box is right to the left
side right to the left to the left side
of the layer that's the check box and if
we click on it now it's unchecked
meaning the game object is not active if
it's checked then the game object is
active we can even see it in the scene
and we are doing this exact thing in the
code with this line of code said active
is false will not make it active and
it's not visible in the scene and true
we'll make it visible and active in the
scene so this right here tests if the
game object is active if it is then turn
it off because we tried to attack we
activated it but we did not made any hit
so yeah it's not active and now we can
test it out so if I go here you see the
enemy is attacking in and touch the game
object and here I touched him again
and now I touched him and now he will
attack me and he touched me and now I
touch him I know this sounds weird I
touch him he touch me but hey don't
don't think of anything anyways you get
my point and you see how can we detect
collision by using this right here now
we can safely delete this because we see
it is working we printed everything out
so we see that we are detecting
collision so we are detecting we can
touch the player and we can touch the
enemy so we can basically attack each
other the next thing to do is create
this health script that we commented
here out so I'm gonna copy this name
health script and go here in unity and
go back in the project because we need
to subtract the health value from our
enemy when we attack with a player and
vice-versa so in the scripts folder
right click here and create a new
c-sharp script name it health script and
as you can assume we are going to attach
it on the enemy and on the player so
select both of them so select them click
on add component and click here health
or actually filter for the health script
and voila
here is the health
so we need to double-click it and open
it here in Visual Studio
let me just tag the class here because
inside of our health script we are going
to subtract the health value which means
that we're going to have here our public
flowed helped which by default we can
say it's equal to 100 so when we start
the game we are going to have 100 for
the health now here I'm going to remove
start and update and we're going to have
here a public void applied damage which
will take float damage as a parameter
and simply what we're gonna do is we are
going to see here health so our health
variable - equals the damage that we are
passing here as a parameter because
we're going to subtract damage from the
health now this minus equals is a short
hand for writing health is equal to
health - damage so instead of typing
health is equal to help - damage we can
simply say minus equals and it is the
same exact effect and here let me just
tag it so apply damage and here we're
going to test if our health is lower or
equal to the value of zero meaning help
drop to zero here we're going to print
or we are going to say here the
character died so the character died and
here in our attack damage now we can
uncomment this line of code and you can
see here the beauty so we have the
damage here which is the parameter we
set it to be public basically this one
is the local variable and here we have
the as you can see we're passing it as a
parameter we set it to be public which
means we can edit the value in the
inspector panel
so when we call apply damage we can say
for example this value here to be 100
and people subtract 100 from the current
health value then it will test if the
health value is less than or equal to
zero if that's the case we will print
that the character has died now in order
to see this in action I'm going to go
here in the council let me first clear
the car
so that is and if I take the warrior
since we are
if you select here our warrior and the
attack point you will notice that the
damage is one if I set the damage to be
twenty for example and go here select
the enemy and you see here the health is
currently 100 you can pay attention
right here let me just clear my
highlight tool here I'm going to select
the enemy and now when I play the game
you will pay attention to the health
value of the enemies let's go and attack
the enemy so here we are and attacking
pay attention now it's easy then 60 40
20 and one more BAM you see the
character died so the character died now
this is not the effect that we want we
don't want to print simply in the
console the character died instead we
want to do some things and in order to
do those things we are going to create
here a private float X that this is
going to be the rotation which we is
going to be equal to negative 90 because
what I'm gonna do is let me explain
first I'm gonna take the warrior here
and when one of the game objects dies
what I'm gonna do is simply rotate him
backwards so rotate him like this
negative 90 degrees so he falls on the
ground because we don't have a death
animation if I go here in models
some models and animation we don't have
here the death animation so we cannot
simulate that with an animation because
this 3d model for some reason don't ask
me why I don't know so I don't know why
doesn't it have the death animation but
usually you will have a dead animation
and then you will play that animation
but here we're going to simulate that so
we're going to see here private float X
death private float death underscore
smooth so smooth which is going to be
equal to 0.9 F private float a rotate
underscore time which is going to be
equal to 0.23 F private bool which is
going to be equal to or name of it is
going to be equal to player died so what
do we need to do well now we're gonna
get back the update
so you're gonna see here update and here
what I'm gonna say is if player died so
if that is true so if our player has
died we are going to do what we are
going to call a function that we're
gonna call a rotate after death now of
course we did not create this function
so let me just go here hit enter to give
a little bit more space here come on
what are you doing here and here so if
player died if this becomes true and by
the way by default a boolean value is
equal to false so if we simply declare a
boolean value like this so if we declare
it we don't type it's equal to false or
if it's equal to true then by default it
will be equal to false that means this
right here will not be true we need to
set it to be true and here we have this
rotate after that so simply here we're
going to create this avoid a rotate
after death and simply here we're going
to call our transform Euler angles you
see the rotation as ealer angles in
degrees you see this Euler angles is
vector three so we need to pass a vector
three so this is gonna be equal to new
vector 3 and we have now values for x
y&z for our X we're going to use math F
that lerp from transform Euler angles X
towards the X depth in time dot Delta
time multiply that with the death smooth
for our Y we're going to see transform
alert angle is y and for z-transform
Euler angles dot Z so what is going on
right here so what is this well
basically we are going to learn and
learn means you see this matte F lerp it
linearly interpolate between a and B by
D this is a in order to paint the
picture this lerp will go from this
point to this point in this timely
manner so this is point A
so this is right here point a and this
right here this X that excuse me so let
me just go here so this is point a this
right here this is point a this X that
is point B so here we have point B and T
is time so the time interval which is
this one right here time Delta time
multiplied with a dead smooth that is T
or time
now again Y time dot Delta time well
because to smooth things out and you see
here I'm using that smooth so we need to
smooth things out again we will go from
this value towards this value in this
timely interval and the current value of
the Euler angle X which is the rotation
X will be 0 you're gonna go towards the
X that which is negative 90 and
basically that's what we are doing and
in order to activate this what we need
to do is here we're going to create an
eye enumerator not enumerable in
numerator and we're going to call this
one player or actually we're going to
call it a low allow rotate and here
we're going to say player died is equal
to true to allow the player to die
basically it will activate this right
here so it will go here in the if
statement this will be true and it will
activate the rotate after that function
then we're going to say yield return new
wait for seconds and that's going to be
the rotate time which is 0.9 if we go
back here this is the rotate I'm
actually 0.23 so this is the rotate time
and then simply here we're going to call
our player died is equal to false now we
will see in a second why are we doing it
like this so if I go here if health is
less than or equal to zero then we are
going to die so we are going to call
here star co-routine and we're going to
call allow rotate co-routine which will
enable player dead is equal to true
which will make this true which will go
inside of this function
and it will rotate so it will go from
the current X rotation to this the
targeted which is the X depth
rotation which is negative 90 in this
time interval and we will leave the Y
and the Z rotation intact if I go back
now and what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
do that with the player or actually
let's test it out on the enemy because
we have the same script on the enemy
first so if I go here I will need to
attack the enemy five times so one two
three four and notice now when I hit him
five back you see but basically nothing
happened why is that well we need to
also deal with some other things such as
we need to deactivate these scripts if I
select the warrior for the warrior we
will need to deactivate his animator
player moves on and so forth for the
enemy we need to deactivate the nav
agent we need to deactivate the enemy
controller so we are going to start
doing that with this variable so we are
going to create here a public bull
variable that we are going to call is
player so call it is player like this
and when we die so when we die here
inside of this if statement so if health
is less than or equal to zero the first
thing that we need to do is we need to
say here getcomponent the animators of
animator component and we need to say
enabled is equal to false so that we can
deactivate the animator so deactivate
the na main tour now next we are going
to test here if is player so if we have
a player we are going to disable his
script so we are going to see here
getcomponent
player move and we're going to say
enabled is equal to false we are also
going to say getcomponent
player attack input and we are going to
say enabled is equal to false we're
going to do two more things but we will
see that in a second
else if it's not the player so if it's
the
me then we are going to see here
getcomponent we're going to see enemy
controller component enabled is equal to
false and we also need to see here get
component nav mesh agent like this and
we need to see that enabled is equal to
false but you see here we cannot do that
because we need to go here and type
using unity engine that a I so that we
are able to use nav mesh agent as a
component and this able it so you see
here we have is player and we have else
which is not for the player and we are
going to differentiate between the
player and the enemy because they both
carry this health script so what we need
to do is go here in unity and select the
warrior so the warrior we are going to
select him and he is going to have this
is player checkbox checked inside of the
health script I'm going to hit apply to
make changes to the prefab so you see
here that is player is checked but for
the enemy is player will not be checked
and I'm also going to hit apply for the
enemy so that that change applies to the
prefab so for the enemy is player is not
going to be checked so let's test this
out right now and see if it actually
works so if I go here I will need to
attack the enemy for or actually five
times so one more time notice one more
time after I hit the enemy then you see
now the enemy falls and pay attention
you see his Navi agent is not active his
enemy controller is not active so we had
to disable those scripts you see we had
to disable these scripts in order for
this to work because we are simulating
the rotation we are simulating the death
by simply rotating the character to fall
down basically this is what we are doing
so he is falling down and this is how we
are simulating that but since we had the
enemy controller script which was
attached on the enemy we also had the
nabbed agent which was also attached on
the enemy they are interrupt
this process right here so we had to
disable them so we had to disable them
right here so enabled is equal to false
basically means this if I select the
enemy and I disable his enemy controller
script and I run the game you will see
now that the enemy is standing over
there it's not working because if you
pay attention here on the enemy you see
where he is enemy controller script is
you see the checkbox right here it is
disabled meaning this script when not
will not function if I enable it BAM you
see automatically he starts running
towards me because his script is also
running and it is working now let me
take care at the enemy and what I'm
gonna do is for the enemy attack point
I'm going to set the damage to be equal
to 5 to make this somewhat a fair battle
and I'm also going to take the warrior
and set his health to be equal to 5 so
set the health of the player to be equal
to 5 because we want to test this out I
wanna point to show you two issues that
we have pay attention now with the enemy
kills the player BAM you see the camera
went over here and noticed the enemy is
still attacking pay attention the enemy
is attacking and the player or the
camera is at the ground so we need to
add two more lines of code here if is
player so if he is player we are gonna
disable the player move and attack input
and notice here we are disabling the
animator for both the enemy and the
player so your disabling for both again
the enemy and the player because we
don't want their animator to play any
more but here if it is player and we
checked the checkbox for the player so
we saw how that goes so we check the
checkbox if is player then we also need
to do two more things we need to say
here our camera so camera main dot
transform set parent is now equal to
null because pay attention here the
camera and let me just fold all of these
so fold this and this you see the camera
is a child of our player so whatever the
player does so if the player is being
rotated
let me select the warrior if I rotate
the player see the camera is following
because the camera is a child of the
player whatever the player does if he
moves left the camera moves along with
it if he moves right the camera moves
along with him so if he rotates the
camera will rotate because it's a child
of the warrior game object so what we
need to do is we need to set the parent
of the camera null meaning the player is
not the parent game object for the
camera anymore and you also saw that the
enemy was attacking so we need to
disable the enemy script we need to make
the enemy basically not attack the
player and we are going to do that by
calling here game object find the game
object with the tag tags that enemy
tagged so and then me underscore tag and
we need to create this enemy tag in the
tag so going here and here we're going
to say public constant string enemy tag
is equal to here enemy so we're gonna
get the enemy and we're going to see
here dot getcomponent
and we're gonna get our enemy controller
component and we're going to say that
enabled is now equal to false because we
want to deactivate our enemy game object
we can now test this out but we need to
make sure two things first of all you
need to make sure that the enemy is
tagged with the enemy tag and that the
camera main is also tags if I go back
here select the enemy you see that the
enemy is tagged with the enemy tag
select the camera and player so this one
right here see the camera in player and
it's untagged so we need to select this
main camera tag it is built by default
so by default it is immunity so select
the camera and player and put the main
camera tag on it because as I said this
camera main it's built in unity and if I
hover over it will say the first enable
camera tagged main camera so in order to
do this or use this in
code we need to tag the camera with the
main camera and if I test this out well
because I have said the help of my
player 2/5 as soon as the enemy attacks
me notice now I'm dead the enemy is
standing still he is not attacking me
because we disabled his enemy controller
script as you can see he is playing his
idle animation and I'm land or standing
here dead or laying down dead and the
camera pay attention the camera is now
free if I select here it is you see
camera in player is now free it's not
under the player game object it's
completely free it does not have a
parent game object any more basically
this is what we did so again here
briefly we are testing here if health is
less than or equal to zero this is clear
when that happens we will disable the
animator we want don't want to animate
we will allow to rotate and we explain
here what we are doing because we only
want to rotate 90 degrees angles we are
going to allow the rotation wait for the
rotate time and this able or set the
player that died is equal to fall so
that we don't so that we don't activate
or don't do this anymore because if I
remove this right here you just go and
test it out so if I go here and wait for
our enemy to come closer come on unity
run the program run notice now when the
enemy hits me BAM you see you see this
is the reason why this is the reason why
I am allowing and then not allowing so
if I see here player died true that we
will allow to rotate then we will not
allow to rotate you saw the reason why
because this right here will execute
over and over and over and we don't want
to allow it to glitch as you saw a
moment go so what is the next thing to
do the next thing to do is to display
the health values to our user so if I go
here immunity I'm going to create a UI
canvas now I cannot go too much into you
I I will cover that in
other video so it will be too much this
video is already almost I don't know
three hours anyways I'm gonna right
click here and go under UI and create a
image so let's go here and create an
image and this is our UI canvas and I'm
going to name it to you i canvassed and
we're going to leave it at screen space
overlay which means basically it will
overlay the screen but I'm going to set
this canvas scalar script to constant
pixel size to screen with screen size or
scale excuse me not screen with screen
size scale with screen size reference
resolution is going to be 1280 by 720
and I'm going to stay here 0.5 to match
width and height equally basically what
I did here is that this canvas will take
this reference resolution and like its
main resolution and it will try to make
these game objects apply or resize
according to this resolution as I said I
will cover cameras and everything
specific to the canvas in a separate
video so now I'm gonna right click on
the canvas and create an empty game
object and this empty game object is
going to be our player held it's gonna
be empty as I already said and we're
going to set the width and the height
1280 by 720 and the first thing that we
are gonna do with this play your help
I'm gonna right click here go under UI
and create a text component and I'm
going to rename it here to player text
and there inside of the text we're going
to type player this is what's gonna be
displayed I'm also going to align the
text at the center or actually we're
going to align it left but Center so
left here Center but from the left side
the font size is gonna be 59 and I know
that you currently don't see the text
but you will see it in a moment the
color is going to be white so click here
on the color if you ever work in
Photoshop or any other editing software
in regards to images you will you will
know these options or any text software
so you know the alignment you know what
is the font size you know what is the
font style bold italic nor
son and so forth now for the width of
our text I'm going to say 3 8 6 and for
the height I'm going to say 81 I'm also
going to set here the anchor at the top
left corner basically this will make the
center of the player the top-left corner
so this is the anchor it will make the
center of our text top left corner the
position X is going to be 214 and the
position Y is going to be negative 40 so
this is the for our player the next
thing to do is create our VG which is
our image I'm simply going to drag and
drop it here under the player help so
drag and drop the image and I'm going to
rename it to BG set the anchor of it to
top left corner and the width is gonna
be 228 the height is gonna be 29 and I'm
going to set here the position X at 130
and the position Y is gonna be negative
101 now I also need to duplicate this
health so I'm gonna duplicate it
this BG and I'm going to rename it to
player health display and for this one
we need to go here in our project and UI
and we have this health you are which is
simply this image this white thing right
here but what we need to do is we need
to select it and in the inspector panel
because if I try to drag and drop it
right now here it's not gonna work and
let me just clear here I can drag and
drop it here for the image to represent
to be represented by that image but it's
not working now because the default
value or the default texture type of
this image is that the default you need
to click here on this right here it says
texture type so you need to click on
that and you need to select this price
2d and UI and hit apply at the bottom
right corner so now we are able to use
this health UI as an UI or actually drag
and drop it here and simply create a
health UI from it
now again you don't see the difference
but now I can click on the color and I
can change the color to red which you
see but what's most what's more
important I can click on this image type
inside of the image script I can click
on the image type and I can set it to be
filled and I can change this from radial
to horizontal and pay attention now when
I move the slider left and right so you
see I'm moving the slider left and right
and we are filling up the so we are
filling up the image with this red value
we are filling it up you see and
lowering this is going to be our health
this is going to display the help so
what I'm gonna do is duplicate this play
your health and rename it to enemy
health so here enemy health and I'm
going to take the text and it is going
to be enemy text and position is 214 but
I'm going to set the anchor at the top
right corner and the position is going
to be negative 214 and the alignment is
going to be on the right side and here
we are going to say enemy like this for
the BG we're gonna do the same thing so
X is 130 set the anchor at the top-right
corner and this one is going to be
negative 130 and for our enemy display
health so change it from player to enemy
health displayed I'm going to set the
anchor at the top-right corner and set
the x position to negative 130 but you
see now we need to change the origin of
the field because it is filling from the
right side we need to change it to the
left and this is all or this happens in
all of these options so right here so
you see the fill right here I change it
from left to right so select on this
drop-down let's change it from left to
right so now when we fill you see it's
going from this side or from the left to
the right now what we need to do to make
this happen you simply go here in our
visual studio and in the health script
right here we also need to type below
using unity engine 8i we need to type
using UI so unity engine dot UI
and right below our public bull is
player aiming to create a private image
which I'm going to name help you I and
we made it private because we don't want
it to be accessed in any other class so
don't want it to be accessed in any
other class but we also want to drag and
drop so we want to drag and drop these
health display values in appropriate
slots so you see here we don't see them
but since we made it private I'm simply
going to see here serialised field and
it will make them visible now in the
inspector panel so you see now they will
be visible in the inspector panel so for
the warrior drag and drop the player
health display and for our enemy health
or actually for the enemy drag and drop
the enemy health display so for the
warrior we have the warrior or player
health display for enemy we have the
enemy health display and inside of here
inside of our apply damage right here
after we subtract from the health the
damage value we are simply going to say
here if our health you I so health UI is
not equal to know so we have a reference
we're going to say health UI dot fill is
equal to the health value but we need to
divide that by 100 because if you go
back here immunity you will see that
when you select let's say for the player
help display if you select it you will
see that the fill amount goes from the
value of 0 up to 1 so it goes from 0 to
1 it cannot go from 0 to 100 so from 0
to 1 that's why we are dividing this by
100 because if the health current value
is 100 and we subtract from it to 20
that will be 80 80 divided by 100 it's 8
so that's why we are actually not eight
but point eight excuse me so 80 if we
divide 80 by 100 so 100 that's equal to
zero point eight and it will fill that
image amount so if we go back here in
unity what I'm going to do
is set the warrior helped back to 104
the enemy held so select the enemy the
help is also equal to 100 so what we
need to do inside or actually now is
simply test it out so if I hit the play
button let's go here and pay attention
out with enemy attacks the player you
see now pay attention to the players
health value it's decreasing and also
when I attack the enemy you see I'm
decreasing his health value decreasing
even more and even more and even more
and when I hit him one more time he dies
and as you can see he is lying dead and
basically this is how we are going to
this is how we are going to display the
health value now that we are displaying
the health value let's shield ourselves
from the enemy and in order to do that
I'm going to go here in scripts and
right click and go here c-sharp script
and create a player shield script as you
can assume this is only going to be
attached on the player so select the
player and drag and drop the player
shield script on him hit apply so that
that change applies to the prefab go
here and double-click player shield and
this one is going to be a very simple
script here we are going to have private
and that is going to be our health
script so health script which I'm going
to call health script and in the awake
function we're going to get a reference
it so awake here and we're simply going
to say health script is equal to get
component health not head off health
script component and here we're going to
have a public void activate shield which
is gonna take a bool shield active and
what we need to do here first of all we
need to go in the health script and we
need to create here a public public bool
and this one is going to be shield
activated and it is public because I
want to access it here because I want
see here health scrip that shield
activated is equal to this value here
shield active so it will be either true
or false so that's why I want it to be
public I don't want it to be private
because if I set it to be private it
will not be able to access it here you
see is due its inaccessible due to its
protection level so we cannot access it
because of its protection level so we
need to make it public I but I don't
want it to be visible in the inspector
panel if I go here and select the
warrior pay attention to the player
health script I don't want this shield
activated to be visible here so what can
I do same is here serialized field for
the private variable we can say open
square bracket hide an inspector for a
public variable and it will be hidden in
the inspector panel now what we're gonna
do with this shield activated is here on
top of our apply damage you see I'm
going to see if shield activated I'm
simply going to see return now you're
like but we cannot use returning a void
function yes we cannot use it to return
a value but if we say here return this
will break out of the function what do I
mean by break out of the function
imagine like this if this is true when
we entered this apply damaged function
so this is the first thing that we are
going to check if this is false then we
will proceed down to execute the rest of
the code so from here up to the bottom
where we have the code inside of this
function but if this is true if shield
activated is true and we hit this return
statement we will exit out of this
function so we'll go outside and we will
not proceed below to execute all of the
code that we have so we will not proceed
to execute the code basically we will
exit out of the function in order to see
this in action I'm going to go here in
our player attack input right here and
right below our public game object
attack point we are going to create a
private player shield which I'm going to
call shield in the awake function we are
going to
the shield is equal to get component and
we are going to say here player shield
component and simply here when we defend
you see when we defend we are going to
say shield that activate shield is true
and when we release the J key we are
going to see here shield activate shield
is now equal to false which will go
inside of this script right here it will
call this function and passing here true
or false it will assign that value to
the help script
shield activated which is this value
right here again so it's this value
right here shield activated and if that
is true it will return and break outside
of the function and we can test it out
if I go back immunity let me just clear
the console this works only if you press
the J key and hold it you can it does
not work if you press and release it if
you just press it and release it it will
not work so you need to press and hold
it pay attention now if I go here so if
the enemy attacks me now pay attention
to my help it's gonna subtract again
it's gonna subtract and now I'm gonna
hold the shield pay attention to the
health value pay above pay above pay
attention above you see the player
health value is not is not decreasing
while I'm holding if I release now he is
going to subtract value if I press and
don't hold you see if I press and don't
hold it's not gonna work so you need to
press and hold so press and hold for it
is to work because this is what we're
doing in our attack input if we press
the key down then we will defend if we
release the key up then we will well
release the key and then we will not
defend so you need to press and hold for
this to work and release then for it -
well not defend itself any more so this
is for our defense
the last thing that is left for us to do
is create our sound effects so let's go
back in unity and I'm going to right
click on our Warrior
create an empty game object this is
going to be our player sound like this
and here we're going to click on add
component and filter for the audio
source component and voila but I'm also
going to uncheck this play on awake
checkbox so don't check this because it
will play a sound any clip that we
attach here on awake we don't want that
I'm also going to do the same thing for
the enemy right-click on the enemy and
create an empty game object and we're
going to call this one enemy sound and
here attach the audio source uncheck
play on awake and go here in our project
and in scripts and right click and
c-sharp script I'm going to call this
one character sound FX select the enemy
sound and the player sound so select
them both click on add component and
attach the character so character sound
effects voila
and we do need to hit apply for the
enemy and for the warriors so for both
of them so that that change applies to
the prefab and now open so select the
player sound or character effects sound
script open it and what we are gonna do
here is we're going to get a reference
to the private audio source so here on
top private audio source which I'm going
to call sound FX and we're going to do
that in the awake function so awake
sound FX is equal to get component audio
source component we are also going to
have here private audio clips so audio
clip attack so attack underscore sound
underscore one attack underscore sound
underscore two and die sound simple like
that now they are private but we don't
want to allow them to be used in other
scripts but we are going to make them
serialize field because we're going to
drag and drop them and here
we are simply going to create a public
void attack function underscore one so
attack one and we're going to play the
attack one sound so we're simply going
to say sound FX that audio clip or
simply clip is equal to attack sound 1
and simply call sound effects dot play
to play that sound effect it's simple
like this programming is beautiful if
you want to change a clip that's
attached to that audio source dot clips
you say sound effects or the audio
source that clip is equal to the clip
you want to attach sound effects or the
audio source that play to play that
sound and I'm going to duplicate this
function and this here is going to be
attacked two and we're going to attach
the attack to sound and here we're going
to have our die sound so public void die
and we're going to attach here the die
sound and play the die sound it's simple
as that now this character sound we're
going to have in our health script we're
going to have it in our player attack so
let me just go here play your attack
help an enemy controller now what we
need to do is we need to declare here aa
private in the health script that is so
private and we're going to see here
character sound effects and we can call
it sound effects so I can call it sound
come on sound effects like this and
inside of the awake function so void
awake we are going to see here sound FX
is equal to get component in children
like this and we're going to say
character sound effects now why get
component in children because if we go
back here you will notice that this
player sound is a child of the game
object we cannot say get component we
use get component on the game object
itself so if we for example we have the
warrior game object if you want to get
the character controller then we will
say get component because it's attached
on him but if we want to use this script
characters sound which is attached on
the warrior then we need or actually
excuse me attached on the players
sounded which is a child of the warrior
then we need to use getcomponent in
children and pay attention this only
works if you have if you have only one
script attached so if we have a
duplicate if we have two player sounds
it will work but it will get you one of
these it will not get you both it will
get you one of these so when you have
one like here player sound it only has
this character sound effects then you
can use get component in children and it
will get you that one component and
since we are here I'm gonna go quickly
in sounds and here we have arena so
these are arena sounds unit and these
are attacks on so you can preview them
you can click on it and preview it here
this is attack one or tag zero here we
have this one and this one I'm going to
attach these two so select the enemy
sound and play your sound I'm gonna
attack attach man attack one and man
attack - for the sound attack one and
two and for the die sound let's see this
one yeah this one can do yeah the second
one I mean you can play with these and
you can take any one that you want so
for our players sound I'm going to
attach death - and for our enemies sound
I'm going to attach I don't know that
night I'm not gonna even check it out so
I'm gonna hit here apply and apply for
this one as well I'm not even going to
check it as I said because well we don't
care we have the attack sound we have
the dead sound so it's not important how
they sound so let's go back here we have
the sound effects and we are going to
get it here and when we die so this is
where we die in our health and if health
is less than or equal to zero we are
going to call sound effects die and this
will work both for the player and both
for the enemy so when they die they will
display the die sound and before
test it out I'm gonna go also here in
our player attack so right here I'm
going to create private character sound
effects and this is going to be sound
effects and simply here sound effects is
going to be equal to get component in
children character sound effect and I'm
going to copy this line of code because
we're going to use it in our enemy
controller and when we attack so this is
where we are attacking so here I'm going
to call sound effects that attack one
sound and here I'm going to say sound
effects dot attack to sound simple as
that it's very simple so when we attack
with the one attack sound attack one
when we attack with the second attack
attacked two and we're going to do the
same thing here for our enemy so if I go
here in our enemy right here at the top
private characters sound effects sound
FX right here in the awake below our
player target sound effect is equal to
get component in children and get that
component and when we attack here so
let's go in the attack here it is attack
and him one so we're simply going to say
sound effects attack one copy this and
paste it below and attack dude this does
not require any explanation because it's
self-explanatory I've explained it right
here so we are going to call the clip
and attack and here simply set the clip
to the clip that we want and play it set
the clip to the clip that we want and
play it and voila it's gonna do that for
us and we're calling this one we attack
so when we attack we will play attack
one sound and attacked you sound when we
attack with the second attack this is
what we're doing for the enemy and for
the player as well now in order to spice
this up we're basically done with our
game so we are done and in order to
spice this up what I'm gonna do is right
click here and create an empty game
object this is going to be our BG sound
and I'm going to reset the position and
attach to audio source components so
audio source here and another audio
source so two of them because I'm gonna
go here inside
the sounds and arena and we have these
arena sounds so you see and this one
also so pay attention what I'm gonna do
is select the BG sound and for the first
one attach that arena one sound and for
the second one on Rena underscore due
south and pay attention here play on
awake if you don't check it so if it's
not checked if I run the game we will
not hear these sounds so if I run the
game the sounds we don't hear them so
make sure that you check these
checkboxes so I'm gonna check play on
awake let me just find it play on awake
and loop loop means when the sound
effect finish is to play same like on
your it seemed like in your mp3 app so
when you click loop it will repeat the
song so check here play on awake and
loop and notice here it's warning us
that we have to audio listeners in our
game now the reason for this is because
we have one main camera that has an
audio listener and we also have another
camera that's attached on the player
that has a listener so you see here
camera here and camera here so I'm gonna
take the main camera at this one that's
not active and remove the audio listener
from it because this is the audio
listener that will be getting that sound
and make us hear the sound effect now
also one thing that you have in this
audio source is the volume so pay
attention here have the volume one it's
100 so I'm gonna go over it for arena
one I'm going to say point four for
example and for arena 2 I'm going to say
I don't know point 25 maybe because I
don't want that sound to be heard like
we heard it a moment it goes too loud
for our game and practically
congratulations this is our game we are
finished we can test it out to hear the
sound effects so I'm gonna shut up so
you see here and let me just check here
again we have two listeners so let me
just find where they are so we have you
I where are these two listeners so we
have the main camera
we have here camera rocking player Polly
a listener and the event system I don't
know where the second listener is it
will not hurt our game if you find and
just remove it let me just remove it
from here so select the camera and
player and remove it so let's see if we
can hear it now I literally don't know
where the second audio listener is but
if you find it just remove it I don't
care it's not important will not hurt
our game and we can play our game so
here the sound effects and also pay
attention to the player sound death and
also for the enemy and their attack
sound so pay attention up here I don't
think it's I don't think we can hear it
because of these sounds so BG sound I
don't know this one is going to be at
point two and this one is gonna be at
point one so like this so the volume for
this one actually I set the pitch here
so pitch is at one volume needs to be at
point four it's unit for this one and
for this one point twenty five so it can
work now I forgot I said the pitch not
the volume so yeah set the volume two
point four and point twenty-five for the
second one so that we can hear it so pay
attention now you know we can hear it a
little visit this yeah point one or
point you for the volume here and for
this one is gonna be point one finally I
decided which wall you might want so
here the play button let's test it out
finally so you hear it listen to the
attack sound again
and again so now when I hit him he will
die and you heard the die sound effect
and we can also test for the player to
see if the player can die so I'm gonna
set the health value to 5 and we will
die instantly just so that we can test
that that dye works for the player as
well to pay attention now
voila so the dye also works for the
player he is that the enemy will be
standing still because he well we talked
about it we deactivated scripts so on
and so forth now congratulations this is
a big project even though it's not that
big when you look at it visually we
don't have 20 players fighting with each
other but we learned combat we learn
melee battle system we learn how to deal
damage how to subtract health and all of
the good stuff that you don't see in any
other tutorial online basically you
cannot find this anywhere else on
YouTube so yeah tanki awesome dudes and
you're welcome
anyways if you want more awesome
tutorials go on awesome to comm
subscribe there more actually awesome
sitcom go on YouTube / awesome tubes and
subscribe on my channel and you will
have more cool tutorials like these
until then fire here and by the way you
can download this complete projects of
this complete project and all the assets
link is in the description below until
next time bye your hair from passengers
calm I will see you guys in another
video